well good morning everybody and welcome
to this informal virtual meeting of mid
suffolk district council development
control b meeting
the decision to hold an informal meeting
has been taken as a result of the
current risks relating to covert 19
pandemic
as this meeting is now an informal
meeting the committee members will not
be able to make decisions and therefore
will not be voting on any of the items
on the agenda
members are asked to discuss the items
and to confirm us dear to the chief
planning officer for each item
at the conclusion of each item i'll ask
the chief planning officer to indicate
whether he's minded to accept the
recommendation made in the officer
report or to take any other action
having listened to the discussion
mayor remind you of some domestic
arrangements please ensure microphones
are turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
if you are attending to speak and
consistently interrupt you will be asked
to leave
please remember to use the chat function
only to indicate that you
um
i think not the chat function um please
can we use hands up because i can't keep
an eye on hands up chat and everything
so can we use the hands up for
if you wish to speak
please note um that messages in the chat
panel can be viewed by everybody
watching the broadcast
i'd like to remind everyone present that
it is an informal meeting and will be
broadcast live to the
internet and will be capable of repeated
viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering the meeting as a speaker
you're also consenting to being recorded
by the council and the possible use of
those images and sound recordings for
webcasting and all training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast the meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
so the introductions we've got to the
chief planning officer phillip isbell
you can see him there good morning
now that's gemma
okay good morning chairman apologies sir
timothy pushing the wrong buttons yeah
it gets like that so that's um our chief
planning officer mr phil isabelle and we
have the area planning manager um gemma
walker who's there
morning joe
good morning do we have uh john payton g
with us
just myself this morning chair just
yourself right thank you and the case
officers we have alex scott are you
there please good morning
good morning kathy yes good morning and
we have rose walton are you there as
well please
morning
morning rose
and vincent pierce
good morning chair
morning vincent
and overall goadie
morning chair good morning overall and
we also have our governance officer
alyssia norman please
morning chair good morning and in the
background we've got bethany who's uh
driving all this uh electronics
so if i move to the agenda things will
be slightly different but we'll move to
the agenda and move forward
with good
good heart
for the roll call for the members
present please
thank you chair good morning members uh
if you could please respond when i call
your name uh counselor castin
present
thank you councillor guthrie
i'm here
thank you
uh councillor melon
present
thank you
councillor mayor good morning get here
thank you
councillor miller good morning present
thank you thank you uh councillor norris
president
thank you council stringer president
thank you and councillor war voice
president
thank you
i saw you
thank you to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interests by
members anything to declare i'll leave
it a second or two
no nancy declare ah councillor mellon
yes
uh just to say that i'm the ward member
on the on the first application
yes that's fine thank you very much
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
uh none received chair uh just a note
sorry that counselor stringer has his
hand up yes i've just seen that come
through but we'll just cover that bit
and then cancel a stringer if you would
please just to declare the interest for
the item in backton i i'm the county
councillor for that area and i've been
in discussions with the applicant about
highways issues
lovely thank you very much for that
information
thank you for that
um do we have any site inspections
and luncheon
schedule of re reports well we'll do
them in the order in which they sit
which i think is comfortable
so we have the first application and
that's um alex to introduce the
application of dc2100641
bounties of turkeyville lane so if you'd
like to present the case and we'll
listen to that thank you very much
thank you councillor guthrie yes uh i
can just uh present my screen and
hopefully we'll have the
and uh you can all see that and try and
get
full slideshow so that's as quick as
possible
there we are
okay so this is um
item six a on the agenda
um sorry gotta be careful what i say
reserved matters application reference
dc forward slash 21 forward slash double
0 641
land to the east of turkey hall lane
backton
and the application before you seeks
approval of reserve matters following
outline planning
outline planning permission reference dc
forward slash 18 forward slash double
zero 725
for 51 dwellings that included
affordable housing 18 affordable units
and public open space and that was
granted in july of 2018.
the
current application seeks approval of
matters relating to layout scale and
appearance of buildings and the
landscaping thereof only
with matters of access previously
included in the outline planning
permission
now the application was previously
considered
by this committee on the 4th of august
2021
and the decision of members of that time
was to defer the the item to a future
committee for the points raised at the
meeting
these include looking at the layout
in its entirety and design
with particular attention to a an
apartment block to the south of the site
which there were several concerns
relating to several issues from uh from
members
and uh further ecology assessment as
well and um
[Music]
what we've done is as officers is go
back to the um the applicant and seek
amendments and um what you're about to
see is is the result of those
discussions and uh there's been a full
reconsultation on all uh all additional
information provided to us so uh yeah i
hope that sets out
the position clearly
uh on to the presentation this is the
location of backton for the avoidance of
doubt within the district
and
the blue circle is the approximate
location of the site
within the village
this is the constraints plan and the
site the site itself is outlined in red
on the screen
and this blue line is the existing
settlement boundary as
for the existing development plan that's
the
local plan 1998
and
other key constraints we have a listed
building here
grade two
and the main uh
stone market this railway line runs uh
adjacent to the site as well
so i think those are the main main site
constraints
this is an aerial uh aerial view of the
site
just give an idea of what it looks like
from above
this is the site
location plan approved as part of
the outline planning permission
this is the layout as currently
proposed revision p 20 and this is a as
a result of the um
[Music]
amendments discussions and amendments
which have been had since uh the
application was last at committee in uh
in august 2021
and just in summary um
the key points of uh
your attention and um and amendment uh
the public open space
uh to the
the southeast of the site has been uh
redesigned to flow into the center
of the site here
and
it has been designed so as to be more
overlooked by by proposed dwellings
so frontages of dwellings here here here
and along and with active windows
also fronting from both the north and
the south so that is in response to
concerns members had previously as well
now the apartment block um which
previously sat in this location adjacent
to dwellings
in north close has been completely
removed from the
scheme
and
it's been replaced by
two private dwellings plots 50 and 51
and these are both bungalows
can you just point that out with your
pointer please
um yes if you can see this counselor go
through that is it
clear
are you seeing my pointer i could i can
see it i'm sorry i apologize if you
can't um oh yes yes yes yes
you can yes oh good for everybody to see
it yep that's fine yes you can see that
thank you thank you
um
so yeah and
yes and the apartment block has been um
redesigned and located to the far north
east at the of the the sites
and
there is a second that there will there
was a second apartment block on the site
for two-bedroom
affordable units uh that has now been
removed and
uh
the affordable component has been
replaced by uh
two-bedroom um semi-detached or detached
uh dwellings in uh in this location i
have a um affordable housing plan um
in a few slides time so i'll confirm the
locations to you shortly
um we also had an updated ecology report
provided since august by the applicant
and that has been assessed by um
your consultants at place services
ecology who are
in general agreement with the um
the findings and the
mitigation proposed
there are also seven additional um
allocated parking spaces proposed
across the site
different to what was previously
proposed in august so more parking
and
there's also some
some progress which has been
made in terms of discussions with
with highways with regards the off-site
highways works um to turkey hall lane
and those are set out in a um in a
section of the report for your uh
um for your information
and yes we're happy to discuss that and
um clarify any points um that that you
may have
um so just moving through the remainder
of the presentation here is a close-up
of uh the south
west portion of the site
and then
the northeast portion as well
as mentioned before
the locations of the affordable housing
the the purple indicating shared
ownership the uh the light blue um
indicated for affordable rent
and now previously those were uh
bunched in this area of the site and um
a few out here uh that that has now been
more spread out um
in response partially to uh concerns
raised by members previously that they
were um a little bit too clustered so um
yeah affordable dwellings now
more spread out around the site
the proposed elevations um these are the
proposed market uh dwellings
we have 10 bungalows included within the
scheme
and these are the
semi-detached
market units
and the proposed affordable units and
just to indicate the active windows
threatening the public open space
from
the plots in the in the 40s
and this is the new um affordable
apartment block which has been
redesigned and relocated
as seen on the layout
and i've included this slide just to
show you um
what has been removed from the
scheme as previous and what what has
been replaced so what you see on the
left of your screen are the designs
which have been
removed
and what you see on the right of your
screen are the new designs which have
been
included in the current scheme before
you
so this is the uh apartment blog which
is raising uh
a lot of concern
from members previously so that's not
been lost completely
and for good measure we have the
elevations of the garages the detached
garages which will be uh provided across
the uh across the site
and here is the details of the
proposed pumping station um to the uh to
the northwest of the site um next to the
one of the proposed attenuation basins
and that has been designed and screened
um
further to advice from uh your heritage
officers um as the listed building
or the cartilage is in close proximity
to this uh
this boundary here
and some street scene elevations for you
show how the scheme would sit uh
site
now this was the um
this was the the layout which uh members
saw indicative at the time
when the outline
planning application was considered
and just laying that next to what is
currently proposed so what is currently
proposed
on the right of your screen
what members saw in terms of outline on
the left
and for good measure we have um the
previous layout which members saw in in
august 2021
and that's laid next to
what is now currently proposed
hopefully that's helpful
now onto some photographs this is the
junction of
turkey hall lane and pound hill
and moving down turkey hall lane
and this is the start of the site here
looking across might be able to see the
uh the listed building neighboring
and uh we've now turned around looking
back down turkey hall lane and these are
the existing dwellings
uh at the top of north close
then looking across the field
itself
and this is
a google uh street view image taken from
the top of north close showing the
existing uh relationship in terms of uh
public footpath provision and um this
area has been um
uh sort of questioned as it is proposed
to have a
footpath
potentially running across this site
linking into north close
and this final slide has been provided
by
engineers at suffolk county highways and
the light green hatched areas here
indicate land within uh
suffolk county's
control
for uh
particularly with guards proposed
off-site works um would be relevant
so uh that uh that concludes the
presentation and um the recommendation
as set out in um in the report is um
to recommend to the chief planning
officer that uh reserve matters be uh
be approved um for the reasons given and
subject to the conditions as recommended
thank you
thank you alex um am i right in thinking
that that um previous slide which showed
the uh footpath proposal that that
particular area is being improved that
highways have agreed to improve that am
i right have i got that from somewhere
um i'm not aware of any uh proposal but
uh then i haven't been directly party to
any uh any such conversation scraps
councillor stringer's got his hand oh
philip yes
should we take andrew first and then yes
i was gonna say councillor stringer
might be able to help me on that one but
i'm sure i heard something along those
lines maybe i'm wrong counsellor
stringer
thank you chair i i wasn't putting my
hand up for that but the
the county council does indeed own that
paved area although up until a week ago
they were denying all knowledge of that
so there is no promise of any upgrade
from the county council sadly but there
has been extensive talks about
trying to get a footpath from this site
up to pound hill in the existing highway
to improve pedestrian safety but that
forms part of the section 278 works
on the outline permission
so what i wanted to do it would be very
very helpful alex if you could point out
saint mary's playing field and its
relationship to this site because it
does inform why the parish council
objected to the
uh the difference between the two green
space office
thank you
can i just before you go on that you
mean the ones that are now being offered
andrew cancer stringer
yes yes sorry chair yeah then obviously
there's a whole actually it's a really
good submission i think by the parish
council it's quite comprehensive but it
goes into great detail about
they were they were disappointed with
the change in the offer and if you if
you recognize its relationship with the
existence of marriage playing field that
helps explain that situation okay thank
you
okay so i'll go back to the presentation
and
get a slide showing some mary's playing
field um
so i believe some areas playing field is
is here adjacent to the site at the top
of uh something areas close
that's as my understanding
is that correct andrew cancer stringer
yeah that's correct but if you then show
the maps of the original outline
the original outline yes yeah yeah yeah
i think in our in our own papers i think
it's page 70
um anyway it just helps explain it yes
of course yes
you do the one where it's got the two
you know where it's got the um oh yes
that's the other one and then we can
sort of eyeball it together
outline left uh what is currently
proposed on the right yeah so mary's
playing field in this location yes
all right thank you
chairman it jim just just to complete
the the gap you asked where that come
from so i i had a conversation with um
county officers about that area of paved
surface i believe councillor string has
been in discussion with them about it it
does need
uh does need attention and maintenance
being polite about these things and as i
understand it that county uh are
intended to act on that so
that's in hand i think if you look at
google street view you'll find its
condition shows it does need some work
um
and i think you know with the increase
in usage here the county will wisely
invest in in
in that little space so that that
provides a connection that means you
don't have to rely on turkey hall lane
as a as a walking route thank you german
ah it's very useful uh councillor mellon
i think it was did i see yes um leave
that slide out that might be helpful to
councillor melon you wanted to speak yes
of course
um yeah thank you um
how much more questions and help from
you as well of course yeah sure um
um alex you mentioned in your
presentation that you're happy to just
clarify things on the um
the off-site works um so i hope it's
okay to come in with a question on that
sure any questions questions
yeah so in the um the outline permission
there's condition 11 which is about the
uh
the um off-site highway works um so i'm
just need clarification about how that
um condition is going to be discharged
because it obviously hasn't appeared
in the two
um discharge of conditions applications
that we've had
um and it seems to sort of very much um
be based on that one plan that was
presented at outline um but i understand
there's there's different plans now in
the mix but i'm not clear how
that is going to be exactly passed
um i'm assuming it wouldn't come back to
this committee just for discharge of
that condition
um well no
certainly i mean it's not usual practice
to take um discharge of condition
applications to to to committee as i
understand but um yes i mean there is um
that there's going to be some difficulty
um in uh conforming to that that plan as
i understand
therefore what we're potentially looking
at is a further application to vary that
commit sorry that condition
and um
that would be and uh section 73 of the
act of the planning act and um
uh should we as an authority be minded
to to grant that that that would sit as
a standalone permission um as i
understand so
can i can i just come in on this
please
yeah um so condition 11 is a requirement
so it's not a something to be agreed
it's a what you do
um so it specifies a drawing and an
expectation so to that extent uh
councilman we wouldn't actually expect a
submission under it you do it like that
that's what you do and you do it before
occupation
because the conversation about the
requirements of that have moved on
the option to change the drawing uh the
technical detail to align with the
section 278 is what's being pursued
and
that will follow on from this expect i
mean that's what will need to happen but
as the condition only triggers that
occupation
you know we've got quite a lot of build
work and um in terms of ducks in a row i
think what you're seeing is
do this first and then come back to that
but there's been discussion about how to
deal with that condition
and
uh the solution is uh
from my point of view probably a
non-material amendment rather material
one a material amended is a section 73
application a non-material amendment is
a slightly different beast if it's if
it's a matter of small details within
that technical uh
drawing to reflect what actually is or
isn't highway then i think that's
non-material but it wouldn't come back
before the committee it wouldn't in any
event have been the matter of submission
it would be something simply which is
you do it like that
and that was the expectation so
those are the kind of mechanics of it
does does that help at all and chairman
whilst i'm on i noticed you've also got
hands up from councillor muller and from
councillor norris if councilman hasn't
got any other questions that follow on
uh yeah i think you'd be very easy to
get kind of snarled up in a discussion
about this which doesn't form part of
what we're discussing today but i i
think there's still
significant concerns because it shifted
so far from what was proposed
and really
as you've seen in the bundle significant
concerns from the community
um and from myself
um
about uh about that off-site works
i mean i understand that thank you jim
yeah do you understand that
thank you we now have councillor muller
please
um thank you chair um two questions if i
may please chair the first one relates
to paragraph 5.2
electric car charging points are also
proposed with each garage proposed can
you please advise me what's the position
with regarding electrical charging
points for the other properties please
and the second question i have regards
on page 31 it's something that the
parish council have raised about
play equipment suitable for both
able-bodied and disabled users of all
ages on the open space
are there plans to put any play
equipment on the open space please
thanks very much alex
okay thank you councilman yes um in
terms of ev charging i mean yeah quite
right those
are proposed to be within
within the garages um i don't have a
proposal
um in front of me in terms of
the other properties which don't have
garages so maybe that's a question for
the
the applicant's agent we do have them
here so uh
perhaps i can uh clear that up in terms
of the public uh
or the the place based player equipment
proposed um that's secured as i
understand by section 106
and
further details of um equipment
provision will need to be um negotiated
as part of that agreement thank you very
much alex thank you chair
thank you um phil can you just clarify
um regarding the charging points at the
moment because we're still waiting
yes chairman so i am rules i i
understand from um
uh
the corporate manager for building
control uh that uh the partel changes to
the building regulations that are
going to require the inclusion of
eb charges from june um and uh
that will be with within all new
buildings and extensive renovation works
so um
from from our point of view that's kind
of swept up within changes to building
regulations chairman
um
uh
yeah and as alex says on the on the open
space point yeah the um the open space
scheme is part of the 106 and has to be
agreed uh as part of uh as part of a
separate requirement thank you jim
you've got councillors norris mayer and
warboys
but just coming back to you on that
point um this application has been in
prior to any changes so um
i'm not like
i've not checked with the with with um
uh the corporate manager regarding any
grandfather rights about this um so i'd
have to
that's a matter of
and see where you come from on that yeah
yeah okay councillor norris then please
thank you chair uh page 11 within the
responses from national consultaes the
second one down from anglian water
reads having reviewed the applicant's
feral drainage strategy consider
that the impact on public fell sewerage
network has not been adequately
addressed at this stage
my question is is it intended that any
measures will be taken to address this
thank you
um well it's i mean it's my
understanding that um
the obligation is that the applicant
would need to
to make provision for that
um
i don't know if any of my uh senior
colleagues can help out with a bit of
that
well if that's the case could this not
be conditioned
so so chairman um just going through it
the um
outline permission does and i'm just
looking through the document and
obviously it's not a short document so
if you can just
uh bear with me there is a condition on
the outline permission
condition 18
condition 18 thank you gemma yes which
requires a foul water strategy to be
agreed
so
uh clearly at outline stage there's some
anticipation that how how water is
managed and there's also surface water
management as well as two other
conditions is part of the uh
part of the agreed sweeter conditions so
this being reserved matters for layout
appearance
within the conditions on the original
committee committee have already taken
taken a step to get that it was just
that i was saying here that at this
stage which i was questioning so it
appeared to be still outstanding but
it's still part of the overall approval
okay thank you it's not settled from our
point of view as officers now i don't
think we've seen discharge a condition
request yet
it is confusing when we've got to sort
of
um look at the two aspects of it and we
are literally looking at
the layout scale of the buildings and
etc and everything else it's a bit like
a tacit agreement well you can have it
but you can't do it until you do that
well the whole idea of outlines is to
get principals agreed you know they
allow you to invest a certain amount of
of time and effort in getting a a
decision
um but obviously they do expect that
some matters will will follow on um just
while i'm on and after my chairman is
also in the table papers there's a late
comment from uh
designing out crime team and the
police
and i think albeit they've made some
comments about lighting and the open
space
arrangements they're not objecting from
what i read in that chairman so just
draw that to your attention whilst we're
going through the conversation because i
think it was a com i think on the uh
report you'll see it's one that we were
waiting on when we when we brought this
to you
yeah
things catch up with us don't they yeah
yeah absolutely thank you
councillor norris has that sort of um
given you the answer you had
asked for yeah
yeah thank you
yeah if you take your hand down then
counselor maya thank you
yeah um
construction management plan
um my question i assume that's part of
the outline
conditions um but if so how does that
relate to the works on turkey lane
and
a follow-on question um having had a
similar development in my own ward where
the construction management plan was
just largely ignored and villages
suffered accordingly and is there
anything we can do to strengthen that to
ensure the developer adheres to said
plan
um yes thanks councilman mayor um yeah
construction management condition 13 i
believe of the outline planning
permission
and
um
yeah that requires several
details traffic routes
uploading appliance materials wheel
washing lighting uh
location and nature of compounds with
storage areas
um waste storage and removal temporary
buildings
dust management measures noise and
vibration management litter management
specifically
and that is required
prior to commencement um
[Music]
now usually that would deal with i
believe
uh just construction of the site and um
not off-site highways works if i'm
understanding correctly
my issue is not the highways works but
if turkey lane is going to be part of
the access to the site but we've got
site works um there's potential for a
clash there
well yes i mean in terms of the traffic
direction that is um part of what the
construction management would seek to
address
so we're saying that they would liaise
with highways to ensure that the two are
um
done parallel
so so chairman i mean we've got
from a quick look at planning history we
do have a submission on condition 23
which is the construction management
condition
it was largely designed around
biodiversity
as an objective
but
you know one of the points of this
conversation is to take that away to uh
resolve that with county highways
dealing with the section 278 that
relates to those highway works and yes
they do need to
be satisfactory together and at the same
time um if
members think that's something that's uh
you know significant um if you leave
that question with me i'll have a think
about a condition that we might put on
this decision in order to ensure that
there's coordination
so that there's no
undue
impact from those works uh cancer so if
you can leave that one with me i'll have
a think about that as a potential
condition thank you
i think you're frozen mr israel
i think everybody's frozen are they are
you frozen uh don't you just froze
momentarily i'm afraid
uh and i think cancer string and castle
warboys still have their hand up
yeah yeah but you were just slightly
frozen
it says
bad bad network quality call me back it
says oh my word
maybe that's mine
right uh councillor stringer if you
would please thank you
thank you chair uh indebted to
councillor maya for for raising the
issue of uh the
uh
the highways management
because
the the parish council has has
endeavoured to talk to all the
developers in backton about this issue
because one thing also missing from the
presentation was turkey hall lane is the
official lorry room in and out of the
village to avoid the low bridge
for the norwich london main line
so
all of the traffic
for the building sites of which there
are five building sites of more than 50
homes in backton running at the same
time
um will be up turkey hall lane
so when the section 278 works are
carried out are you turkey or lane is
closed
uh
the management of this is is going to be
absolutely critical
so i mean
given that suffolk county highways
normally only object to something or
have a problem with something if
if it can demonstrate that it's the
impact will be severe
how how are we able to get sight of
whether the management plan will be
acceptable in reality because it's not
just about the impact of getting in
there this site it's the impact of also
delivering all the other sites that have
been approved in this area
shall i come back in on that chairman
yes please so yeah um so
uh my experience is that
documents exchanged between planning
authorities and developers sometimes
don't always sweep in the
uh necessity to actually have the
individuals who are site managers on the
ground party to this conversation
so just going through the outline
permission um condition 13 related to
the construction management plan
we couldn't and shouldn't reimpose that
condition but i think in terms of this
layout and its delivery we can certainly
uh
seek a condition to ensure that
any details under that
uh are
uh demonstrated to
manage the relationship with any
off-site highway works
and to be honest the applicant is here
if you hear from them i think there's
probably what i would call a common
sense local conversation required
between
uh
the developers actually constructing the
site the parish and probably ourselves
as a conversation about what
and how that is managed on the ground
because for all of the pieces pieces of
paper that we exchange
uh it is usually uh most useful to
actually have a direct telephone number
from the chap who is the site manager
through to the parish council and an
understanding that that line of
communication
is open to dialogue and cancer strength
if you can assist with that that would
be helpful because i think that's
that's entirely territory for county and
district members to kind of
make sure everybody is talking in real
time
actually what i was trying to do was
that conversations being had and the
majority of the developers are speaking
with the parish council and our good
selves to try and sort this out
my fear is that in between the documents
going to county and ourselves with
perhaps not all the information that we
actually inadvertently approve something
that undoes some of that work that's
going on on the ground that that's my
concern i think my concern is there any
chance we can have sight of what is
proposed
uh just to make sure that
there isn't any errors in that that
would create what we don't want to
create ie
catastrophic circumstances i mean we
have had we've got two sites running and
we've had up to three diversions in the
same village
within the same week already uh and this
is getting you know increasingly
uh
at odds with highway safety and actually
the safe delivery of these these housing
sites
okay jim well i think that's something
that we can certainly
let's see what the applicant's got to
say about that they'll have heard this
conversation
i think that in relation to the details
you have here you can impose
a condition to ensure that these
elements are uh given attention
in relation to the management of
construction and that point of dialogue
is built in uh and i think that's a
conversation to follow on from this
gentleman if
if cancer has already got those
conversations going on with back to
parish council and
cancer has those
however it happens
i think it can rather than create some
formality of undertaking the point in a
meeting like this i think it's really to
say when we actually need to make sure
those conversations are tied together
between the individuals involved and you
know that might well involve uh alex
getting directly involved in dialogue
with yourselves as that condition um
goes to our process because the way we
handle conditions is uh partly supported
within
our support team and partly by officers
so that they work together and that
there's more than one person involved in
this conversation to
achieve that um discharge thank you jim
i think that's very useful all round um
right so we're sort of pretty informal
here at the moment and we will continue
to be so so i think we've got all the
hands have been given the opportunity
and so if we move on um
we have um
the i'm just trying to think of the
order we have the applicant here you
said um
we don't have the parish council is that
correct alicia have we got on this
uh that's correct chair we don't have um
the parish council or an objector or a
supporter but we do have the agent jake
lambert he's here right okay then mr
lambert if you you're hearing our
discussions going on here so if you'd
like to give us your three minutes and
then um members might want to sort of
query one or two things with you so if
you'd like to take that away please
thank you alyssia i'll leave it to you
certainly yeah thanks chair and um
thanks everyone and the opportunity to
speak today um the report provided by
your officer as well as today's
presentation a very comprehensive and
i'd like to say a few points about the
application which if permitted will
secure the delivery of much needed
housing including policy compliant
affordable housing on a committed
development site
following deferral of the planning
application from development committee
on 6th june and 4th of august 2021 a
programmer meetings were held with the
parish council and local community in
backton in august and september 2021 to
comprehensively review and refine the
proposed development in particular the
open space provision was revisited and a
solution was identified which maximised
benefits for both existing and future
residents while addressing surveillance
and security concerns raised by members
previously the relationship between
existing development on north close has
also been comprehensively revised with
the previously proposed apartment block
relocated and replaced with two detached
dwellings for a more spacious outlook
for these properties
affordable housing has also been
redistributed more evenly throughout the
site to respond to concerns raised by
members and the council's housing team
furthermore as alex mentioned an
addendum to verify the ecological
appraisal associated with the outline
planning consent has been undertaken as
requested by members of the august 2021
committee the addendum report concluded
that the site remains suitable for
development and mitigation measures
outlined in the approved construction
and environmental management plan are
suitable the addendum report has been
endorsed and approved by the council's
ecological advisors
and the amended scheme has received no
objections from technical statutory
consultees including the highway and
flood authorities as part of ongoing
engagement with the parish council works
at turkey hall lane have been reviewed
carefully and a safe and deliverable
solution has been agreed with the local
community and the highway authority
in conclusion flagship have
comprehensively revisited the scheme
with the local community resulting in a
better development the proposal
represents a high quality sustainable
solution to bring forward a committed
development site in the emerging local
plan just to add on top of that the
flagship housing group is a registered
provider of social and affordable
housing who reinvest any profit made
from the sale of their properties into
providing more affordable homes
throughout east anglia this model of
profit purpose provides funding to aid
with flagship's vision to solve the
housing crisis in the east
which these much needed high quality
homes will contribute towards we
therefore respectfully request that
councils resolve to approve this
application in accordance with officers
recommendations
i'm joined today by peter watlington
from flagship housing group
and would be happy to respond to any
questions you may have so thanks very
much for your time
and thank you do members have
questions for mr lambert please
counselor melon
yes thank you chair can you just um
confirm um
what is the timetable with the off-site
works
my understanding i think from our
previous discussion was that
you were going to do the widening to
turkey hall lane first before you got
onto anything else on the site
that's that's my understanding um i say
a um a construction method statement um
as alex mentioned um has been submitted
as part of condition uh to discharge
condition 13 of the outline planning
consent part of a separate application
away from this reserve matters um
application and yeah in terms of timing
of work that's that's that's um that's
kind of the first um first phase
ultimately um works to circuit online
yeah so so nothing else will be going on
site until you've got the the road
sorted out
that's my understanding
thank you
councillor muller thank you chair just
to clarify the point i raised earlier uh
mr lambert um what is the position
regarding electric car charging points
on other properties other than those
with garages please
yeah so um
yeah so alex mentioned already that um
all properties with garages will be
provided with a ev charging point um
that's 27 in total and um so a um a
sustainability statement was submitted
um again it's part of a separate
application to discharge condition 19 of
the outline consent and um and as i say
it's those 27-27
dwellings that will be served by those
um ev charging points um the
environmental um sustainability officer
at the council is happy with that and
has kind of endorsed that approach so um
that's that's
my understanding that's what the
applicant would will be proceeding with
um as agreed with um with offices as
part of that separate application
so there are no plans to put electrical
charging points on the other properties
um peter i don't know if if that's an
opportunity for food to come in on that
but but as i say um
the the the strategy that's that has
been put forward has been agreed um
with with this kind of the
sustainability officer already and
that's my understanding but yeah peter
if you'd like to come in on any feature
version so
yeah by all means um thank you for for
pointing my direction um just to advise
you councilor muller that yes we are
looking at renewables and um and these
points and issues obviously with regards
to ev charging points this is something
that is on our agenda to look at um we
are looking to provide ev charging
points to houses without garages also
this will be um
revised and revisited upon um final
completion of
the drawing packs so yes we will be
looking to put ev charging points on
dwellings without garages also
thank you gentlemen thank you chair
thank you maybe mr isabel you can mark
that as one of your points for review
as uh yes councillor mayor you have a
question too thank you
thank you um
gentlemen the the roads within the
development will they be built to
adoptable standards and will they be
offered to suffolk county council for
adoption
they will indeed yes um we would be
building them to adoptable standard and
we will be looking to have them adopted
under section 38
thank you
thank you very much
that's fine i don't see any more
questions for the applicant um or mr
lambert so thank you for your attendance
we will go um
and
although we're debating as we're going
along we will debate a little more and
if there's something that you might need
to help us with i'm sure we can call you
in in this type of meeting so
um if you'd like to switch your videos
off for the time being um and i think
it's now counselor ah
sorry counselor casting you had a
question sorry that's a late one there
and i see councilman that's it yes
counselor cast in just a moment yes yeah
my apologies um madam chair i was very
late in fact you were you were wrapping
up that part as opposed to
it it just um occurred to me to ask if
um there's any plans to adopt the um
suds
the drainage systems
or um and what main how the maintenance
on those will be handled going forward
okay um
yeah so as part of the outline consent
um one of the conditions as part of that
was to agree um the surface water
drainage strategy um in detail um and
as i say a separate application has gone
in to to to do just that and the flood
authority are happy with what's proposed
and kind of management procedures are
have been packaged up um as part of that
as well um so as i say um
the kind of management procedures and
how that will be
arranged um as being agreed with the uh
with the flood authority as part of that
separate application
okay are there any plans for anglia
water to adopt
any of them or to offer them to angular
water
um again um just just going back to that
those separate applications to discharge
conditions um i believe it's condition
um
condition 18 i believe this um
requires agreement of the foul water
drainage strategy um and again that's
been done as part of the separate
application angry and water are happy
with them with the scheme proposed as
part of that application um and yes i i
believe that they would be looking after
valve servers and
that that that built by this department
yeah but sorry this is the um this is
the maintenance of the um drainage
system the two ponds um
if
eventually they get silted up or
anything is there something in place to
um deal with that is there a um
is there a management company or
any way of dealing with that sorry i
probably could have been a bit clearer
with that question
if if i may uh counselor casting yes
there will be a management company
employed on this scheme and they will be
looking after that so it will form part
of our management company charges and
will be looked after they will be
maintained to flagship's high standards
also
okay thank you
chairman if i'm just coming on that um i
mean there are uh i think three
conditions on the uh outline permission
that deal with surface water effectively
managing the the way in which it's it's
dealt with
uh and if you've got a surface water
management plan which is uh in an
inherent part of that which and due
course we we will consult the lead flood
authority on so we have
you know we have a close eye on the
surface water management um
uh and obviously the the foul water is a
is a is a different uh different aspect
can i
bear in mind
this isn't this isn't a formal meeting
perhaps i can just come back to the
point that cancer string arrays with me
around um
and that others have talked about in
relation to construction management and
just make sure that
um
mr lambert mr walpington a a
understanding that
we need to establish uh clear points of
contact on site
they got a requirement to detail the
construction management plan
i would expect that to include contact
details and an arrangement for liaison
locally so that
uh as as we we don't have to have the
situation that we've had elsewhere where
i have to send the enforcement officer
out to have a polite word with somebody
which then leads to all things
escalating up changing it would be
better
practically if we can sort this out so
that that direct point of contact for
both ward members for ourselves and for
the parish council exists to build in
um
dialogue direct when the site
construction starts and i don't know if
i can just turn that question over to
the two gentlemen that would be really
helpful to hear their thoughts on that
indeed thank you mr as well yes um we
have already um open dialogue with back
to parish council
to which uh councillor stringer was was
party to where we did meet with um
the other construction companies that's
that's working in the in the area and we
have already open dialogue and how we
would look to to develop a construction
management plan in coordin in accordance
with batson parish council's
requirements so the ways in and out of
the village how we would then look to
manage that construction management plan
and we do already have um
the buy-in of other
developers in the area as well so we
would be looking for site managers to
have individuals so their own telephone
numbers so they could be in contact um
going down turkey hall lane as well we
would look to manage that from our site
perspective as well with banksmen at the
top banks at the bottom to ensure that
um that there is safe passageway through
through that that area um because that
is the main
bone of
contention here is we are going down to
a single track lane and we are looking
at heavy goods vehicles going down there
so we do have agreements with um
i believe three of the other developers
um one of the developers didn't want to
attend that meeting with the parish
council that is something that we
continue to work with the parish council
and councillor stringer and melon to uh
to make sure this is resolved and that
will be provided to alex and yourself in
due course once we've
agreed everything
okay
thank you
thank you
thank you very much um thank you
gentlemen as i say and we may call you
in as it moves forward um but we now
have um councillor mellon who's the ward
member if you'd like to
give us your views on this and of course
um as we move forward we can continue to
include you
if something crops up that you can give
us some help with on this so
thank you over to you
yeah thank you chair
um as you've seen um
committee members this application has
gone through several revisions before
reaching the current layout
and i'm happy to say that i think this
process has improved the layout of the
development and dealt with most of the
concerns
that residents and the parish council
and myself were holding
the application has come before the
committee previously twice
and been deferred on both occasions
um i'm very glad to see the improvements
that have been made subsequently um the
the removal of the apartment block and
the parking court and the undercroft um
i think this is a significant concern
for neighbouring residents so i'm glad
that that has been amended
i have had concerns raised by two
neighbours
for the residents of the listed turkey
hall immediately adjacent to the site
and the residents of elder cottage which
is further downstream
both are concerned about surface water
exceeding
the capacity of the ditch system
um
the open space has been moved around and
i'm now reasonably happy with the layout
uh with the green space um more
dispersed across the site
um the overwhelming concern
as i've raised earlier this morning is
the access via turkey hall lane
not only is this a single track lane but
it is also a route for school buses and
hgvs avoiding the low railway bridge at
pound hill
now the original application applicants
provide um promoted this site
on the promise that turkey hall lane
would be widened to 5.5 meters
from the new estate access up to pound
hill
essentially making it a two-lane road
now this was fundamental to the decision
to grant
outline permission and it was enshrined
in condition 11 of the outlying consent
but having found that 5.5 meters cannot
be delivered
we now have alternative proposals uh
which on page 19 of the report we are
told that highways and engineers have
informally agreed to and as mr isabel
said earlier this will likely be passed
as a minor
amendment
it's extremely frustrating that the
series of decisions mean that this site
has essentially been promoted on a
fundamentally false premise
i know of no other development of this
size 51 homes where the access is via a
single track road which is also a lorry
and a bus route
and what from what i've seen the
solution proposed is going to deliver a
permanent problem for all vehicles in
this area
but i'm happy with all other aspects of
the scheme
i'm very happy that flagship have
engaged with the parish council and the
local community and have promised to
continue to do so but the access remains
a major
major concern uh now now the developers
have said they will do the access first
but the chief planning officer says it
will only be has to be done before
occupation so i find myself
somewhat confused
thank you chad
yeah well perhaps um mr isabel can just
clarify the last point you made can we
oh certainly yes absolutely yes happy to
do that um so uh the point is you can do
it anytime you like
but if you don't do it by the time you
occupy the dwellings my enforcement team
will be coming coming knocking on the
door so
uh the question is really it's up if
they say they're going to do that first
that's absolutely fine but it's not
required by the um by the condition
so it's a matter of the developer's
choice um and
to that extent
you know doing the timing of it is is
for the developer um
you know the the point for our point of
view in highway improvement terms is
that the
enhanced traffic issues only occur once
you start to have the uh residents
occupying the dwelling
okay well we'll sit on that one for the
moment um and i saw alex shaking his
head when um the first thing about 5.5
meters alex were you just shaking your
head or got a flea
buzzing around apologies for the um body
language [ __ ] yeah no no that was just
in in agreement with um what chancellor
mellon had said um
yeah from what i understand uh 5.5 is as
originally advertised if you will is is
doubtful as i understand that was that
was all chair
right thank you um now um again would
the members have further questions for
councillor mellon but again we can sort
of include you counsellor as the debate
moves forward in this informal meeting
if that's helpful
right
okay um well we've had
what i think is is
almost really good
um debate moving through so
um i don't know how anybody wants to
take this forward um but people who
haven't sp spoken um because we need to
give philip a steer
on things do does everybody want to sort
of have another go do you want to
who hasn't spoken for example
i think counseling
yeah yeah council of war boys let's hear
from you if you would please thank you
yes i i think you know looking through
the layout and the plans
and the comments from the police about
um
how it has improved surveillance and
the rest i think there has been
a very effective um
dialogue between the planning officers
and the developers
my biggie councillor mullen and council
stringer
uh you know i've gone through the
questioning regarding turkey hall lane
and access and then the and
this is responded you know some very
common sense suggestions about leap for
dialogue
and um
and how the um
works will commence
uh my i that is my biggest concern i've
driven down turkey all day you know
it isn't
a very good route for lorries and buses
um
and i'm just wondering how
how that could be tightened up to make
sure
that those
works to tokyo lane are carried out
before
this site is developed
simply it is uh
you know we often really
place the emphasis
on
the harm of a developed site uh to my
mind at the moment
the greatest harm here is going to occur
while the site is being
developed um
so i think the emphasis for me is on
that and i i'd like that to sort of be
really reassured
thank you for that council of war boys
um
do you want me to come in there chairman
yes yes yes
um
so
firstly the the road widening that was
discussed and imposed as a condition
uh came out i think originally as
as everyone's reasonable belief that
that was achievable within the highway
um
and clearly the applicant didn't know
the bounds of the highway but we were
all working on best of educated uh
understanding at the time the outline
decision came through
nobody appealed the decision to
challenge its reasonableness it wasn't a
decision that was subject to judicial
review so
everything rolled forward on the
condition now exists on the planning
commission to require it
i think to that extent uh you know the
usual approach to imposing conditions is
can they can they probably be achieved
balance the probability you know 50.1
percent can these things be achieved and
i think
at the time of the decision if you if
i've asked anybody involved in the
decision making there would have been a
a belief certainly for an officer side
that that 51
was uh well satisfied
uh i think it's probably certainly true
that construction traffic um we've we've
got a standard conduction construction
management um uh condition on this
decision
i think what i'm hearing here needs
uh probably what will actually just
simply bolster the conversation's
already happening as a condition to make
sure that these details come forward in
the right way and in the right
coordination so that the kind of
inconvenience and the kind of uh
obstacles that might be occur might
occur by the use of turkey hall lane
um
whilst construction is going on uh are
as far as possible minimized um and i'm
familiar with the nature of turkey whole
line i i cycle along it very regularly
so i know it's it's state it's
it's it's nature
and uh it's its limitations so uh i
think that's a point well made
and
in terms of uh managing you can never
absolutely manage out all of the
potential risks
but clearly there is something here
which needs to ensure that there is
effective coordination and
as far as possible management as these
details come forward and as that those
works happen um which i'm taking away as
a condition that needs to be uh included
in uh
what we achieve here chairman i think uh
some probably as far as i'll leave it
there
yeah thanks we've got council cast and
then councillor stringer and then i'll
say a few words um counselor casting
thank you very very much madam chairman
um
so
a lot of the um turkey hall lane part
that i wanted to talk about has been i i
think it's been dealt with reasonably
well in the last um minute or so so um
i
think this is a good layout
uh i think the density is is good it's a
it's a nice development to live in i
think that condition 18
is really important to me that that is
um
that
i i don't really know what level
condition 18 goes to but i'm
i wouldn't like to see a sewage works
there that um puts out any sewage in
heavy rainfall high ground water or snow
like some do i think it's completely
unnecessary and it must have capacity
over
exactly what how many houses are on
there because we all know that people
connect to um sewers when they um
shouldn't but um i i think that's dealt
with with condition 18. um the
ev charging points on there i think
every single one of those houses should
be
um able to take an ev
charging point
um that's consumer units and um
and wiring
um i don't know if um i don't know if we
actually got there or whether that was a
promise made by the developer
but um apart from that yeah i can i can
see the worries about turkey hall lane i
think we may be doing the best
we can do
with that
and um yeah i am i obviously don't need
to propose anything because that's not
what we're doing in this meeting but i'm
i'm i'm for this development
thank you very much indeed and
councillor stringer please
thank you chair uh
the
we're looking at reserve matters here uh
and and i think the amount of time we've
had to take on this reserve matters
has been an inverse proportion to the
quality of the original outline decision
frankly
what we now have i think is a high
quality design uh
in almost every aspect uh
it often you might say it shouldn't be
that hard to to get to this position
because this is what all our policies
push us towards high quality design it
is built into all of our plans so this
is where we should arrive at anyway
we we've now arrived at a layout which
actually
is is
more than acceptable um
it does offer less of a connected green
space to the existing green space which
you can see why
the parish council felt as it were short
changed
but
i think i i have to just go back to that
original decision and and how it affects
the highway and connectivity
uh
council warboys was absolutely spot on
when he said how can we tighten this up
well of course in fact we can't because
it's already gone
the the the highways connection
uh was already granted permission and
and all it had to do was just be signed
off by county council highways
uh that there needs to be
a and and and
mr isbell quite rightly said we weren't
aware at the time about these problems
that this would create
you know we in all reasonableness we had
all reasonable belief this would be okay
you had that reasonable belief because
you didn't you don't allow that
correspondence that challenges the
county council's
position from the elected councillor at
your meetings
so
with that just out there uh i i think
we got there in the end just about
uh but it could have been an awful lot
easier had we have had a a tighter
outline permission that had all of the
facts before it
thank you chair but if i was having a
vote i'd be voting for this application
in its present form but what i'd love to
have been able to do and this is the sad
fact we are now
about to approve
detailed permission
and we still can't tell people
exactly what works are going to be
carried out in that highway which which
actually is is the cart before the horse
frankly
thank you for that council of stringer
councillor mueller yes thank you chair
yes i too i'm really happy with this
revised application and uh like uh
councillor stringer if we were having a
vote on this i would actually be voting
for it thank you chair
thank you for that
uh councillor mayor
thanks jeff um yes i
support this application um
i've been a counsellor for three years
now and you learn as you go along and
the one thing that i i take from this
and other applications is when we're
considering outline applications we need
to look and consider access to the site
in more detail
um
how whatever precautions and
preparations we have put into place
when this site is being developed it's
going to be a nightmare for the for the
village um
i've had it in my own ward um and it's
currently unavoidable at the moment but
we as a councillors need to take far
more cognizance of
how are these vehicles going to get to
the site to deliver what's proposed but
yeah it's a good development i will
support
thank you for that counsellor um
i was very grateful for councillor
stringer bringing up the issue that in
fact we have done an awful lot on really
what was the previous application and
that we hadn't concentrated too much on
what we were viewing today
but clearly the other issues i felt
needed airing and running which is what
we allowed the the meeting to do
um
i too look at the design and i i think
the improvement is is really good
and i welcomed um alex scott's
comparison of the before and after i
thought that was very useful
and i think the designs on the on the
properties are much improved
um
i do um
take into account the access uh i've had
a very similar thing here but with
smaller numbers councillor stringer um
so i have
my heart goes out to everybody and
counselor mellon
on this but i'm hoping that um
good
sense will prevail um
and i hope we don't put the cart before
the horse because
that really would aggravate everything
and make things unpleasant so i hope
that mr isabel can go away with
the view that
that access
would be better done first rather than
later
and that anything else the improvements
between the county with the county
councillor and the parish council and i
do see that there's been a lot of work
with the parish council although you can
please some of the people some of the
time but not all the time but i think
many of the aspects have been much
improved so i too would would like an
application like this to go forward and
if we
were voting i would be encouraged with
what we've heard today
so mr isbell do you want to sum up what
you think you've heard and i'll correct
you if i think you've heard incorrectly
thank you chairman yes so i think where
we've got to hearing what's been said in
this discussion i'm minded to accept the
recommendation to approve these reserve
matters
i have heard quite a lot of conversation
about the importance of ensuring that
construction management
is knitted together so that any off-site
highway works and the other developments
in the village are coordinated
effectively and i think this is one of
those unusual cases where the reserve
matters here and their delivery it makes
sense for
us to uh include a condition so that
the reserve matters
uh are
that that that coordination happens in
essence
through an additional condition chairman
so that the delivery of the 278 works
the delivery of these matters are all
knitted together and that the
construction management plan required
under the outline includes you know um
identifiable points of contact with
phone numbers and you know ways of
actually directly uh making a link you
know at that most local level so that it
can be most immediate and most effective
and i was heartened by what i heard from
mr lambert mr walpington
but i think it still gives members
reassurance to include a condition to
ensure that
that submission is is under the outline
is picked up as we as we sign off these
reserve matters
i also picked up a requirement to
look closely at the ev charging points
and to include a condition uh requiring
those and i was intending to do that
as far as the matter of surface water
drainage and fail water drainage i mean
we consult um
we we do consult
both the flood authority and
anglian water for advice on those
matters and we would expect to do that
as part of the details of the outline
what i'm getting here i think is there's
quite a lot of interest in making sure
this happens in a way which
everyone understands
is doing its best to try and minimize
impact
i think
one way of doing that is for my officers
to
engage in a bit more direct
dialogue about the plan to
discharge all the conditions to deliver
the development and to get that program
timetable in a in a format that we can
share between the developers ourselves
and the applicant and
that's not a decision notice point
chairman but i'm going to take that away
as a thing to ask alex or uh
area manager to follow up so that we
knit together
all of the various the surface water
flooding the foul water flooding the uh
the the management of traffic issues so
that nobody gets any nasty surprises
because i think that's that's um going
to be for the for the best for the
community here so
with that in mind chairman effectively
i'm i'm taking it that i've got a couple
of extra conditions to add around
uh construction management around ev
charging and to uh
effectively ensure my officers build
that link uh with uh the ward member and
the county ward member said that we're
all on one page because i know because
it council stringers raised issues with
the highways team about uh
the improvement of the paid area et
cetera et cetera and so
bringing all this together that's what
we should do as a local in local
government rather than be separate
authorities jim
yes that's interesting because i've got
three things down here that i thought i
hoped you'd bring up which was the
traffic management plan the ev
the widening and actually i put water
question mark so um i think you've
picked up everything we've said so i
think on that basis now if we can have a
short break 10 minutes
and thank everybody for their input
and just as i say have a short 10 minute
break if we may
well thank you very much and welcome
back to this um informal meeting
um i will now ask the case officer rose
walton to introduce the next matter that
we're going to be discussing
which is dc2103874
mote meadow finnigan road old newton
suffolk good morning so rose if you'd
like to make your presentation thank you
very much
good morning everyone uh please bear
with me just a second while i load up
the presentation
okay can everybody see that in full
screen
yep
yep okay brilliant so this application
is a full application for the erection
of 47 dwellings with 16 affordables
together with open space landscaping
earthworks and drainage at moat meadow
finningham road old newton
the application site is in the village
of old newton which is identified as a
primary village within the current mid
suffix course strategy
this presentation is designed only to
provide illustration and should be
considered in conjunction with the
associated report which you all should
have had access to
the main planning issues associated with
this application involve the principle
of development design impact to heritage
assets landscape highway safety
residential immunity and ecology these
are discussed throughout the
presentation
the pink area is the site you can see
the village to the south and brook yard
farm to the north which has a listed
building
the green line is the current current
settlement boundary of old newton and
the pink area
is the application site as you can see
it abuts the settlement boundary
in terms of constraints the site is the
pink area here
there is a grade two listed building
here
a grade two listed building here
and a scheduled ancient monument here
which is the moat that runs around
rockyard farm
in terms of the wider context of the
site and its connectivity
this is the site
there are some services within the
village including a shop here
a takeaway restaurant here
a church here and a primary school here
with the extended footpath as part of
this proposal which will be adjacent to
the site these are all considered to be
in a safe and accessible
walking distance for pedestrians
the footpath areas are here and here
the footpath then stops and is followed
by a short distance of road with wide
grass verges
these then stop and connect to a public
right way leading to the school cross
here
and this is how the main bulk of the
village would currently access these
services by foot
outline permission under application
18666
forward slash one seven
was granted in 2019 on this site for the
erection of up to 56 dwellings which was
then conditioned to be no more than 47
dwellings
the outlying consent included the
approval of the layout landscaping and
access and this is the approved layout
plan of that application
therefore the principle need not be
considered further as it has already
been established
i'm going to show you the layout plan as
proposed now if i could draw your
attention to the north side of the site
and the east side you will see that this
application is providing more open space
i will go back and play that again for
you
this is the proposed site plan and a
basic form
as you can see it largely follows the
layout design of the previously approved
application with open space to the east
and access running through the centre
but as you saw from the previous slide
there is an increase in open space
there's a rough guide on what the
proposal is likely to look like from an
aerial view with the existing
development to the south
this is the proposed housing mix
there is a mix of bedroom
as shown in the purple and orange
three bedroom in the yellow and blue and
four bedroom in the green there will be
16 affordable properties a mix of
affordable rent and shared ownership
the affordable rent properties are
located here identified by the blue
stars and the shared ownership are
located here identified by the green
stars
i take you through the design of the
proposed dwellings i thought it might be
useful to see the direct local character
of the area i will be showing some
photos of house types along the roads
here here and here
which are in direct proximity to the
site
the design of many of these dwellings
are considered to be a little out of
date
and not of a design character that we
would want to replicate on a new
development
which ought to be of a higher quality
and more traditional design
the proposed scheme has five house types
a two bedroom full of person occupancy
a three bedroom five person occupancy
a four bedroom six person occupancy
a two-bedroom three-person occupancy
and a three-bedroom four-person
occupancy
all would be ndss compliant
with air source heat pumps they will all
be electricity only and will provide a
site-wide energy saving of
57.06 percent
and co2 emissions reduction of 35.9
97 is anticipated
this is an example of a street scene
view showing dwellings along the
frontage facing the european space as
well as through the center of the site
the parish council and the heritage
officer have raised concerns regarding
the design and materials of the
dwellings
the heritage officer considers that the
referencing of buildings architecture
and materials that are found in old
newton has only been achieved to a very
limited degree
the heritage officer considers the built
form outcome appearing somewhat
repetitive could be significantly
improved with higher quality natural
materials and an increase in design
diversity with greater variation in
house types
the applicant has made efforts to
improve the design already
and whilst the limited variation and
diversity of the dwellings has been
cited it is worth noting that the
character of this area of old newton is
modern with many gold brick bungalows
which we saw in the photos on the
previous slide
the dwellings closest to the note have
been uplifted
to feature design tweaks with
contrasting corner bricks a string
course porches and finials
all of which are considered to
contribute positively to the local
character
that said and whilst acknowledging that
the scheme has been improved at the
eastern end in the setting of the moat
we are keen to negotiate a further
uplift in design and ask for this matter
to be delegated to officers and
following this informal meeting
so up on the screen now is an example of
the uplifted design these would face the
open space on the north eastern side of
the site closest to the moat
as you can see they would have scroll
finial ridge tiles contrasting brick
string course and brick coins with a
front door canopy and seated posts
this is another example of
the design
throughout the development these would
be located through the center of the
site
showing a mix of materials with brick
and render
and this is another example there's a
row of three terraced properties which
will be found throughout the site
with a brick string course
this is an example of a street scene
view on the western side of the site
facing silver street and running through
the center of the site
this is an example of the dwellings that
would face onto silver street
with the brick string course and
contrasting brick coins
this is a front and side view of those
dwellings that were just shown showing
the mix of materials and design
in a row of three with the brick string
course facing the attenuation basin
which faces silver street
this is the material schedule the red
dots show the properties would have
double roman rustic brown tiling the red
outline dwellings would be orange and
red multi-tone facing brick with flat
top brick arch lentils
expressed in buff brick they would also
have horizontal brick bands and brick
coins
the yellow outline dwellings would have
buff multi-tone facing brick with flat
top brick arch lentils expressed in
orange and red brick and horizontal
brick bands and the yellow outline
dwellings with the blue outline front
area would have masonry render to light
muted colour tone with the side and rear
being buff multi-tone facing brick with
flat top brick arch lentils expressed in
orange and red brick
the access would be located on the
eastern side with the existing access no
longer used the grey areas show the
vehicle access and orange areas show the
pedestrian and cycle paths
and there would also be an extended
footpath from the access to join with
the existing book path to the south
there is a ditch that runs along the
eastern edge of the site the footways
and vehicle access would form bridges
over the ditch
i just wanted to make it clear at this
stage that the applicant has proposed to
relocate the telegraph pole on the south
east edge of the site
and i'll just bring that closer for you
as highlighted here it would be moved
into the site so currently it is
located on a grass verge just on the
corner and will be moved into the site
this is to make way for the pedestrian
footwear long thinning road which will
take um place of the grass verge
the
sec um
highway authority accepts the principle
of the creation of a new vehicle access
on binningham road
this is
the access on the western side of the
site with pedestrian and cycle access
onto silver street and to the
residential area on faulkner avenue
a relocation of the speed limit on
finningham road is required um
to ensure an acceptable highway safety
outcome and the authority
highway authority advises that a
monetary contribution from the applicant
of 11 500 pounds is necessary
the
sec highway authority have asked for an
additional plan in their referral
response
this is the one i just showed you of the
relocation of the telegraph pole the
highway authority have no objection to
this
this is the parking strategy across the
site
each dwelling would have their own
allocated spaces
this is a closer image of the eastern
side so you can see each dwelling is
color coordinated with
their own parking spaces
for example this
purple dwelling would have these two
purple spaces here
this is a close-up image of the western
side
in total there will be 98 allocated
parking spaces and 12 visitor spaces
in heritage
terms the key heritage character issue
is the impact of the development on the
two adjacent northern designated
heritage assets
those being the grade 2 listed building
at rook yard farm here
and the double moat designated as a
scheduled ancient
monument
here
the heritage bodies of historic england
the heritage officer and the garden
trust all observe that the current
layout is an overall improvement on the
earlier scheme
the current scheme emits housing on the
eastern end with the provision of open
green space deliberately incorporated in
the most immediately sensitive area
of heritage significance
thereby preserving the setting of both
heritage assets
this is a recent photograph of the site
with the moat being on the right hand
side of the photo
and this is a photo from the site
looking across the moat towards the
listed building
you can only just view the listed
building through the trees
here
the heritage officers have identified a
less than substantial level of harm
which has been weighed against the
public benefits of the scheme
and which have been outlined within the
report
a landscaping master plan has been
provided showing the retention of the
head drone trees along the frontage of
the site as well as well as additional
planting throughout the open space to
the front would be wildflower meadow and
the open space surrounding the
attenuation basins would be a mix of
wildflower and wetland meadows
this is the boundary plan the green
areas on the northern side are three
meter wild grassland strip an existing
hedgerow the purple lines are 1.8 meter
brick walls matching the adjoining house
the orange lines are 1.8 meter close
boarded vertical timber fencing
the blue lines are 1.8 meter close
boarded vertical timber fencing set
parallel with the existing boundary
and the yellow line
which is quite hard to see but it's
around this face in here
our 0.45 meter timber post and knee rail
fence on the retaining wall
in terms of residential amenity there
are significant back-to-back distances
and the site is not elevated compared to
the existing residential development to
the south
the majority of existing dwellings have
long rear gardens and their boundary
treatments will be retained
the proposed scheme also offers garden
sizes on the south boundary that are
reasonably long
on this basis the proposal is not
considered to cause any adverse harm to
residential immunity to warrant refusal
the applicant has provided a significant
volume of ecology related documentation
including an impact assessment and
conservation payment certificate
counter-signed by natural england
all of the submitted documentation has
been reviewed by the ecology consultant
who raises no objection the consultant
confirms that the mitigation measures
identified in the ecological impact
assessment and the method
statement for reptiles should be secured
and implemented in full which can be
secured by a condition
the section 106 agreement shall include
affordable housing 10-year mix
and affordable housing commuted sum of
34 171 pounds a speed limit relocation
contribution of 11 500 pounds as well as
on-site open space and includes
management of the space to be agreed and
requirement for public access at all
times
just for reference i'll take you through
some recent photos
this is a photo of the site from the
existing access which will no longer be
used as part of the proposal
the aerial image shows where i was
approximately standing when the photo
was taken highlighted by the yellow star
showing which direction the viewpoint is
looking toward
this is a photo from the existing access
with the note on the right hand side
photo of the moat
there's a photo across the site looking
south west
this is a photo looking south along the
frontage of the site where the open
space will be
this is a photo of the existing access
which will no longer be used
this is the site looking south down
binningham road
and this is looking north up finningham
road
and the recommendation is approval thank
you
thank you very much indeed that was very
helpful a very good run through lots of
things there i just have um i mean i
will i know other members will have
questions but i just have a question you
you said on that last bit there that the
access will no longer be used but when
will that no longer be used
uh i think that question might be better
answered by the agent
um but
from the
conditions they will need to implement
the the access as a first protocol so um
it wouldn't be
used for much longer
right right okay um so uh thank you for
that so i'm sorry i've jumped in ahead
of everyone now do we have questions for
the officer please um we had a nice full
explanation there i'm sure there are
lots of questions jumping out
anybody want to ask anything
i see a hand counselor mayor
thanks chair thanks for the presentation
rose um question on sustainability
um i see that the the
console team put in a series of
requirements and one of them hasn't been
met an electric charging point per
dwelling can you add any more
information around that please
uh yes so an electric vehicle
infrastructure the ducting and suitable
consuming unit um will be implemented
for each dwelling and we can ensure that
um by condition
so is that not on the conditions at the
moment
have we not got that there
well simon davidson says in his note of
first of november um
[Music]
many thanks for your going to i view a
few comments to add while the energy
energy sustains season addressing most
of the conditions and electric charging
per dwelling is missing so we're saying
that just the cabling will put in but
not the charging point
chairman i think if you look at the list
of conditions that's why i read it
electric charts so sustainability
electric charging point per dwelling uh
so i think rose has possibly already
covered that yeah i i highlighted that i
was just trying to look at it quickly
it's halfway down isn't it
sustainability electric
yeah no it's it's easily done because
when you asked the question i thought
i'm sure it was there but i couldn't
remember so thank you for that um any
further questions councilman
no thank you all right lovely um
counselor melon please
uh thank you chair um
and um
yeah thanks to um rose for a very very
comprehensive uh presentation um just a
question mark on the access to silver
street at the other end of the um of the
site
i understand there's going to be a
fairly wide sort of footwear and
cycleway there what's to prevent cars
going right through the site onto silver
street
i don't have that information to hand um
from my knowledge the
the access um
possibly wouldn't be wide enough for
motor vehicles to access
um but i will be able to confirm that
with the agent
yeah perhaps you can ask that question
to the agent
do we have the agent here we do don't we
alicia
sorry chair could you just repeat that
do we have the agent here for this one
um we do um mr collins should be here
sorry
miss holland should be here she's the
agent sorry
we'll ask we'll ask the question of her
later if you'd like to hold that one
there councillor thank you
yeah
and next we have councillor wallam
please
thank you chair i've got rather a lot of
questions but they should be fairly
straightforward
um
the the fence the 0.45 fence on the
retaining wall
um i didn't realize there was a
retaining wall i thought that there was
sloped sides to the balancing point is
there a retaining wall and if so what's
the height of the retaining wall please
but if you want to leave that for later
that's fine well hang on why don't we do
a question at a time if you've got quite
a lot and then because you can't write
as quick and we'll get the answers
uh yes so in relation to the retaining
wall i think the agent might be able to
answer that bit better than i can
um
okay but the the basin will be sloped
yeah that's what i thought thank you
right next yeah
now i'm a bit concerned about or would
like to understand a bit more about the
estate road adoption
am i right that the estate road will not
be adopted by county highways
yes i believe that is
correct i don't know mark can you chime
in here at all
i'll have
um hello everyone um
good morning i'm just going to check
through what the highway authority was
saying and get back to you that's okay
yeah that'd be great mark thank you
well there'll be there'll be a couple of
follow-up questions because that as i
read it um the the applicant is is firm
in not wanting it to be
construct uh not wanting wanting it to
be adopted so um my concern then is
uh about its construction whether it
would be constructed to the same
standard
and who would be responsible for
such things as
sweeping gully emptying checking
drainage
chambers and so on
there's there's a list
and this is what makes me think that it
must be being retained
and
the responsibility will rest with the
with the residents there's a quite a a
long checklist of the checks that will
need to be carried out and
just a bit concerned
um about the the level of work that
might be necessary so perhaps
that could be checked or it could be
that the the agent
would um
would answer that
so shall i move on to the next
yes please do um i think um mark's
making a note of all those and the agent
i'm sure is listening so right
now flooding and drainage
um the console team was the county
council floods
and water engineer and
he issued a holding objection in his
email of the 20th of july 2021
he didn't withdraw that objection on the
20 in his email the 22nd of october 2021
and said that further information was
required
um is that objection still unresolved it
appears that it is i can i can't see any
any correspondence withdrawing that
objection
uh yes the objection has been resolved
apologies if that um
no it hasn't been made available
and the
the site is at a low risk from
fluvial and pluvial sources which is
rivers and streams and rain
and the existing drainage features
i.e the ditches would be retained
um the levels on the site have been
profiled to encourage
pluvial runoff and overland flows away
from the built development and towards
the nearest drainage point
and there's also drainage strategy
that's been completed and which includes
just sustainable drainage features
thanks which moves me on to the next
question and
i'm now referring to the the drainage
report and the management plan
for the retention ponds
there's a list of management tasks
day-to-day management tasks
so who will ensure that regular checks
and maintenance work is carried out such
as the silt
removal and so on
and there are also other records that
need to be kept
um like um
records of de-watering times and so on
now if if the pond was taken over by
anglian water one one could assume that
all these records would be kept
um and it would be angling water who
would want to see
the the records
so is there an arrangement if the if the
uh ponds are
in private ownership so to speak
um is there an arrangement with anglian
water
for these checks to
um
the results of the checks and the
records to be maintained
i don't have that information to hand i
can say that the intention of this
development is for the market houses to
be passed over to
havery housing partnership
and so the agent might want to reflect a
bit more on how how that will work out
yeah thank you um
looking at the
footway
there there doesn't appear to be any
footwear in front of
some of the garages it seems to be
discontinuous in including in front of
you might like to look at plots five and
six
for instance or 12 and 13 and plot 29
the um
the footway seems to
not
cross over their garage forecourt and
there's presumably a reason for that or
it's a mistake by the developer again it
may be something that miss holland can
can answer
i can say that there aren't any
garages um just parking areas on this
site
um but the agent will be able to reflect
a bit more on the access to those
um and my last question oh i think it's
my last question
um
is
when we get to silver street are they
are there any works such as putting in
drop curbs required
on the other side of um silver street
and if so have they been detailed
i don't believe um there aren't any
requirements for drop curbs on silver
street
okay thank you
okay
can i just ask you um keith um
those drop curves that you were just
referring to are outside the um
the the the planning application are
they you said on the other side i'm just
um yeah
my point is that people will be walking
out of that end of silver street and
could well cross the road yeah but it's
on the other side you're referring to so
i get my head around your questioning
because yeah
yeah lovely thank you phil you wanted to
come back just to come in rose can you
um and do you have a detail of that
western or can you zoom into the western
part of the uh the left-hand side of
that slide not that western part it's
you can zoom into that that will be
useful
just just so i can pick up a couple of
questions so um for the heart of
eyesight you can see there are some
textual notes and if you can highlight
the area adjacent to the balancing pond
please uh rose
just to the to the northwest side of it
um you'll see there's some notes there
um if you uh can get your magnifying
glass out on the highways plan you'll
see that it actually talks about that
being a footway cycleway link uh and to
answer cancer melons question
i would imagine that will involve some
sort of uh drop kerber access onto
silver street
but moreover in terms of vehicular
access through the
highway plan also includes a proposal
for collapsible bollards uh to prohibit
non-emergency vehicles so the intention
is to provide those
um essentially immediately adjacent to
the dwelling and i think that's
plot 25 which is the one at the
immediately adjacent to that footway
cycleway on the northwest side of the
suds basin so the intention is to
control access
except for emergency vehicles through
that i would imagine that the detail
will include
drop curb access
onto silver street so that cycles can
access an egress
but obviously the developer can provide
the agent can provide a little more
information around some of those things
jim
thank you very much um thank you
councillor wellam and don't um worry you
can come back in as things progress you
know to to ask questions we're on an
informal
day today thank you
yeah so i can move on to the next
question
is rachel good morning cancer ebon you
have some questions
um good morning chair thank you very
much and good morning everybody else
can i just stop you very very quickly
just as i asked you in i think i'm right
that mark might give us some answers
which might help you get your questions
would you allow that for us please
absolutely yeah sorry i'm sorry but it's
one there's one of those lag things
where it showed up several seconds after
i pressed it um so just to confirm that
it i mean quite right the the hardware
um consultant it was uh benches said
that
it was noted that the estate road was to
remain private and they didn't object to
that
so so the answer to the pursuing
questions um from council of welling is
that there should be a management
company which looks after these matters
and i think that isn't listed in the
conditions that should be listed in the
conditions a management coming to look
after those matters
well there is a construction management
plan but yeah it's more like
constructive surface water management
yeah
yeah i think
we could maybe put management company
because there are some common areas
which might want to be covered by this
so
it a bit a safe capsule title would be a
management company to look after these
matters i think
excellent
thank you right sorry about that rachel
cancer ebon off you go your turn that's
no problem thanks very much for that
i've got three quick questions um could
you confirm that the
on 30 mile an hour um
zone on the fining and roadside and also
on the silver street side are going to
be extended so just confirmation that
both of those
will be extended
um
secondly
the footway along thinning
finningham road
in part it is only about 50 centimeters
wide so can you confirm that there will
be
a
a proper
proper width as it were foot way
going from the site connecting to the
corner of
faulkner avenue please
and thirdly
the
on the silver street side there's a very
ancient
hedge
and it says that there will be
it'll be um cut into and
to make a visibility display for the
cyclists and pedestrians can you confirm
how much of that because it
we really wouldn't want to lose
um all of that hedge thank you very much
thank you chair
uh okay and so in terms of the hedge um
i think the agent might be able to
confirm a bit better um
and our borrow cultural report was
provided with the application
um and there were no objections raised
to that
in terms of the
pedestrian walkway
it will be of a
standard
uh width um for safety reasons
um
this is probably the best plan that i
could show
um that shows it and that will join to
the existing
footpath
um
and sorry what was your first question
um the 30 mile an hour zones will it be
that for both um the finning and road
one
and um silver street one and sorry rose
but while you've got that slide up
the the foot way
um right at the very bottom of that
slide is where the foot way the existing
footway starts and obviously that first
section is along the fence line of
a property that presumably is outside
the ownership here so
confirming that that way will go all the
way down to the bottom of that slide
thanks
yes so to my knowledge the 30 mile an
hour um zone will only be extended on
the fining and road side
um and in terms of the the footpath i'm
not able to
answer whether it will go all the way
down
and that might be
better safe for the agent
okay thanks very much because residents
will be left with a
50 centimeter gap um
and then definitely no extension of the
30 mile an hour on the silver street
side the other what's where cyclists and
pedestrians are coming out of the site
to my knowledge it is only on the
finning roadside um but i will double
check that for you thank you very much
and thank you chair
i'm sorry to interrupt i've just had a
thing flash up on my computer say that
it's going to restart so if i'm lost i'm
afraid i'll have to come back again but
whether it does or not technically i
don't know whether it's going to do that
so i apologize if i get
kicked out so sorry
right uh councillor stringer you're next
yeah
actually not wishing to duplicate the
question but actually to amplifying it
really about the speed limit uh given
we've recently extended the speed limits
to 40 miles an hour at the north and
south of old newton at the cost of seven
and a half thousand pounds
uh
i see we've got a figure of eleven and a
half thousand now for speed limit
relocation
yeah how far is this going to be
relocated and where
because that seems like you know a huge
amount of money if it's only going to be
yeah what's being moved where i think is
what i'm being what i'm asking thank you
okay we don't have a plan showing where
the 30 mile an hour zone will be moved
to
um
i will just have a look at the scc
comments um
and just find out that information for
you
thank you i i think what i was trying to
suggest was
if that figure is being
found as a contribution surely the speed
limits could be looked at at both
entrances for safety reasons for that
figure because the figure is for a
consultation
an illegal document
it doesn't matter how much is in it so
so actually what we should be looking at
is all of the safety aspects of it i
assumed that the 30 mile an hour was
going to go past this site on both roads
and i think so did the community
so just so i understand that council
stringer what you're saying is that in
terms of the
contribution towards speed limits that
question
needs to be looked at in relation to
both silver street and
the uh location of the footway cycleway
entrance to the site
and whether an extension there is also
appropriate in relation to
this development okay the original
trigger was because the the site
entrance
at the moment is in a 40 mile an hour
zone
which will require a bigger
sight line
than if it were 30.
so from an engineering perspective it
would need to be inside a 30 mile an
hour zone for it to be built to that
standard it would need a bigger standard
if it was on a faster road
but equally if we if we are looking at
you know sustainable transport in the
ground
why would you then expect a car to
having extra engineering to pull out on
a 40 mile an hour road
but not a cyclist to have some kind of
buffer when he's exiting a 60 mile an
hour road
um i think those are good questions i
don't just looking at county highways
comments cancer stringer i don't see
uh and i don't unless rose doesn't know
something i don't i don't see a huge
amount of clarification
but the point of this meeting is
obviously that those are things we can
take away and can um
can look to build into this
thank you for that yeah i mean
i would argue it's probably situation
normal from suffolk county council
responses to planning applications but
um
we need we need to look at it in the in
in the round and if there is that
contribution that can look at the speed
limits they certainly should look at
them at both entrances slash exits thank
you
thank you chairman
sorry andrew um
do we still have councillor
guthrie sorry i'm muted cancel a war
boys please
uh just a question regardless of things
that could be taken
forward is it possible to
uplift the the design further
at this stage
uh yes we are asking that that be
delegated to offices um so that we can
uh negotiate an uplift in the design
yeah i i think from my point of view i i
like many things about the design
but i think the uniformity of the the
roof fight is a particular
um question mark for me
i think that's a very good point and
rose did say that there was a phrase she
used about something about design that i
forget the phrase you used exactly rose
what was it that you were going to
you wanted something what was it i did
write it down i can't think
but i agree with you councillor warboys
and um i think rosa's got that one in
her radar
yes we will be asking um
for
uh and to negotiate an uplift in design
um which
might include some
more natural materials and undulating
roof lines
can i just ask a question about the four
bedroom properties
um
correct me if i'm wrong but my
eyesight's going a bit now but
are they other rooms do we have an
interior design on on those because
they're semi-detached aren't they and
they're four-bedroom properties i mean
are they
i know i know we can't get into um
standards and what have we are they big
enough for
the purpose they are currently being
advertised
so the upstairs
they're showing so we understand these
to be ndss compliant do we raise
yes
right national standard compliant then
right yeah okay that's across the whole
site is it it is
yeah oh good yeah okay it's just when
you put four bedrooms into two two semis
you know again
[Music]
one might wish to raise that with the um
yeah uh agent chairman and i noticed and
i don't know if it's an old hand where
mr russell's got his hand up no no it's
not an old handy put that up new didn't
you mr russell your turn go for it it's
not that old it's not that young either
um so
so in terms of the design uplift i
didn't want members to be misled into
thinking that we're going to come out
with something dramatically different to
what you see today
we have had meetings with and
discussions with the applicant and i'm
sure the agent will fill you in on
various bits and pieces um we're still
looking for a little bit of
finessing of some of the elements i
don't think you're going to get a great
deal of change on the roof form etcetera
so i wouldn't i wouldn't like to go away
from this meeting thinking that's going
to happen
we've had this discussion several times
and i don't get the impression that will
happen so we're really looking at design
tweaks and finessing some of the looks
of the
houses thank you very much indeed um
councillor stringer
just just wanted to make a point on that
and and amplify that last point uh from
mr russell
materials can make a significant
difference to the appeal or not appeal
of a design
i really don't have a problem with the
very neat roofs i in fact i applaud the
fact they're not punctuated with plastic
chimneys so i think we need to be really
careful about designing by committee
because we're gonna you know trying to
just add i get the point of adding
scrolls and little bits of detail that's
fine but but
these are not trying to be listed
buildings in the end if we can actually
lift the quality of some of the
materials
without just keep trying to add sort of
jewelry to it
we might end up with with a pleasing
something more pleasing aesthetically
i'd rather trade a couple of scroll
finials for lime render and not cement
render for instance because that would
over time be more visually and also more
sustainably appealing thank you
thank you very much
right so as everybody asked all the
relevant questions
in which case um we can now move on um
to our public speaker um yeah we don't
have anyone else other than the agent
kate holland if you'd like to step
forward and have three minutes and
tell us about your designs and
hopes on this matter thank you
good morning everybody my name is kate
holland i'm of invicta planning and i'm
here to speak on behalf of the applicant
keep moat homes as members will be aware
and as roses outlined the site benefits
from an outline planning permission for
47 homes that was granted in october
2019
this application is for detailed
planning permission for the scheme and
includes full information on the
appearance of dwellings together with
small changes to the layouts including
removal of extensive areas of parking
courts and improvements to the eastern
area of public open open space however
fundamentally the principles of the
development remain the same as
previously approved
prior to the submission of the
application we undertook extensive
pre-application engagement with both the
district and county council including
planning housing heritage highways and
drainage and met with officers from
historic england
pre-application discussions were very
positive with an acknowledgement that
the development proposals were an
improvement upon the original scheme
approved as part of the outline consent
during the application we've continued
to engage with various consultees to
address issues of their as they've
arisen this has resulted in improvements
to the design of the homes through the
provision of additional detailing and
architectural features
we've also been in contact with the
parish council to respond to their
comments this has resulted in the parish
council's most recent response which
confirms they are pleased with the level
of consideration given to their comments
the development proposes the provision
of 47 new dwellings which includes 16
affordable homes the development as a
whole will provide a mix of smaller
dwellings rather than the larger
properties approved as part of the
original outline consent
all homes would comply with the
nationally described space standards and
building regulations part m42 this would
mean they will be flexible and adaptable
for future residents throughout their
lifetime
finally a significant focus has been
given to the overall sustainability of
the proposals the development would be
fully electric with no gas provision the
homes would benefit from increased
thermal efficiency and will be served by
air source heat pumps overall the
dwellings would achieve a reduction in
co2 emissions of 36 and energy demand of
57
the properties would have access to
electric vehicle charging points and
would provide a reduction in water usage
and the development would as a whole
would result in a biodiversity net gain
i would like to take the opportunity to
thank officers for working with us to
develop these proposals and the
significant improvements to the original
outline scheme and i'd like to thank
members for their time today and
consideration of the points made in this
statement
thank you very much indeed and members
do you have any questions for kate
holland please
counselor casting
am i here yet amber thank you very much
um
this three meter strip on the north side
of the um development what's the
thinking behind that is there anything
underneath it or what why why is it
there please
no there's not anything underneath it um
it's an ability to
improve landscape into that area and
also to extend and plant in um
additional hedgerow and tree planting to
offset the dwelling slightly from the
boundary
so will that eventually be planted with
hedge or will that's
sorry will that be planted up or will
that stay a strip
there's a grass strip but some of it's
got plantings the trees in it so for
example where the um side wall of houses
face towards the north there'll be some
trees
um in there and the hedgerow will be
enhanced but that's more along the
existing hedgerow rather than
necessarily massively deepening it into
that area
right okay thank you
um thank you for that um that does pose
the question who would would that be the
management plan looking after the trees
then
yes so the site as a whole would be
managed by a management company who
would do um undertake landscaping works
and we did submit a landscape management
plan as part of the submission which
details which fully details what
landscape works are required when how
often um and that would all be
taken over by whichever management
company looks after the site
right thank you
before i come to council of war boys i
saw
phillippi's bell with your hand up or
you put that down again i did german i i
thought i thought better of it and i
thought i'd wait to hear what other
members had to say before i uh before i
chipped in but uh thank you and i don't
know if it's useful in relation to
kessler castan's landscape comment for
rose to share the landscape master plan
just
to kind of put that back on the screen
so members can see the the area of land
that was being talked about right so i
don't know if that's useful thank you
i'll come to you in a minute counselor
boys just one moment
and if you just highlight the
three meter strip that
was in discussion that would be useful
right
thank you
thank you for that
so council of war boys you have a
question please
yeah i i think the the layout of the the
site is good and the provision made
for the uh
scheduled monument
um
it's been pointed out that there's a
high potential for archaeological
fines on the site and an archaeological
surveys will be made um have you made um
there is a possibility nothing will be
found but
if there are substantial fines this
could be quite an expensive
situation have you made provision
within your um
liability for the site for this
yes so actually some of the photos that
rose showed which was by the access and
i think there was a machine shown on
site
that work was to do with the archaeology
so we've already undertaken the
archaeology work um ahead of this
committee and my understanding is
actually nothing was found as part of
that archaeology work um we will be
submitting the details we've been
liaison with the county council
obviously over that and we'll be
submitting the details to the um
district council um because there are
archaeology conditions on the original
consent so we knew that there was
archaeological archaeological work
needed
thank you
thank you very much um councillor wallam
you have a
was your hand up no maybe not
yes it is yeah oh yes thank you pardon
then yes please if yeah
yeah the two two link questions and and
it's going back to the question i i
raised before which is um
if we look at
um the parking spaces for i think it's
plots
um five and six for instance
uh but yeah it's not essential to see
the to see the the drawing um i i'm
assuming that people will sort of drive
in there
and park and then they've got to reverse
out
um but the the footway material is not
continuous
in front of the parking court the
parking bays and so on
um
and i just wondered whether that was uh
an error or a oversight or whether
you're actually going to stop the fort
way at every
every crossing point it just seemed to
me that
to have that as a different
surfacing
would highlight that there may be
pedestrians walking along there
um
and that also touches on the other query
which is the safety of reversing out
because it seems to me that the visitors
space is on the opposite side of the
road and and some of the um
the spaces for the properties themselves
they're quite close together
and the vehicle will have to reverse out
and i'm just concerned about the safety
of that
okay well in terms of the first point i
think
i mean perhaps it is a a materiality um
situation but the idea would be that you
would just continue along and cross over
the
um sort of the front of the driveway the
spaces there shown are are big enough to
hold the cars and so they don't hang
over the footwear so you would then walk
across the front
um so i think it's
you know it's to create more of an
informal street probably rather than
having a designated footwear all along
the edge of the road and but the idea
would be that you could continue across
the frontage there so there wouldn't be
an intention to to stop people walking
um in terms of the parking spaces in
general they all conform to the size
requirements um the adopted parking
requirements
so and um the spaces will have been
tracked to make sure there is sufficient
reversing distance to get out of them
and not cause a problem with sort of
safety
can can i come back
my point about the continuation of the
footway was if it is a different
material
then anyone who's driving into or
reversing out of those spaces
is perfectly clear that that is a
footway it's not part of the drive
and the other the other the point about
the
um the visitor spaces for instance is
that if you're reversing out of the
middle space
you can't you can't see anything left or
right if you're reversing out
until you're halfway across the road and
i'm just a bit concerned about that
uh the point on materiality happy to
have that discussion with officers um
about you know whether there's anything
they would like to see um changed um
with that um visitors based i mean all i
can say is that the county highways
haven't raised a concern um as far as
i'm aware it's been
tracked and and um from safety
perspective it all complies with what's
required i mean driving through the site
you're not going to be going break next
speed um there so vehicles should be
traveling relatively slowly
um
i think that might be a speed restraint
potentially shown there um with the two
arrows um
forgive me i haven't got the highway
plans in front of me so it might be that
vehicles are up on top of a
a ramp there anyway so should be going
slower
yeah i'm looking at the drawing it does
appear it does appear that there is a
table there in front of the spaces
absolutely yeah
thank you
another issue there um
councillor welum i mean i always have
this sort of comment if they can reverse
out they can reverse in
um but that doesn't seem to happen in
life does it
i think the reason the reason for my
point was that no i know i'm i'm just
passing a comment yeah
if the spaces are a bit longer than
standard then you're not as far into the
road yeah and you can actually see left
and right yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay um thank you for that very useful
points um cancer ebon you have a
question there
thank you very much chair um
and thank you for your um your comments
uh
with regards to a question asked earlier
about um the
cycle and pedestrian exit onto silver
street
um
that's
that currently that stretch is currently
a national speed limit
and for members
sorry no that's me there's drilling
going on
where i am apologies um
for members information the the 30 mile
an hour
zone ends exactly at that
south western corner of the site so it's
its national speed limit from there so
the question was how much of the hedge
it's a
very well established hedge along silver
street along that side of the site
um how much of that would be taken out
um for
um it says for a visibility
display for the cyclists and pedestrians
to see
but presumably that would be much
smaller amount if it was a 30 mile an
hour limit and and does that have to be
quite a big section taken out thank you
thanks chair
i can't give you the exact dimensions of
how much hedge um needs to be taken out
at this point but it would be kept to
the absolute minimum
um i believe the hedge is set slightly
back from the road so there is a space
between where the
um footpath cycleway would join the road
and where the hedge is so hopefully that
would minimise it as much as possible
obviously is only a footpath cycle link
not a road so that should further
minimize how much needs to come out i
think silver street is relatively
straight so you should be able to get
good views in either direction um so it
would be minimized and obviously we are
seeking to retain as much hedgerow as
possible and plant additional hedgerow
around the site um in the places where i
think along the northern boundary is
quite poor so we're looking to enhance
that as much as possible
um thanks for that yes it is quite
straight but also it's
of that on that patch um but also that
means because it's a national speed
limit um
you know unless you're going to extend
it the 30 mile an hour zone up there
which i really hope does happen um that
would cause a problem but thank you
thank you chair
um councillor welum did you want to come
back i'll see your hand up
councillor
now he's gone right um can i just ask mr
isbell to comment and then councillor
stringer if i may please thank you yeah
thank you chairman um yes just just
picking up a couple of points because
councilwoman didn't quite completely go
where i i thought he might have gone um
and uh so by the look of it the design
and accepting you're not familiar with
the the highway elements of this does
seem to show a raised table at that
southwest west end where the where the
little spur private drive is
and you had that previously i think rose
on that on that drawing
um
so
we're still expecting emergency vehicles
to go down that
connection so presumably you your
impression will be there be a drop curve
and presumably you're content that we
you know given the fact that we're now
going to be expecting the potential for
emergency vehicles to access negros that
we will need to look into visibility
either way and to look at where the
speed limit is or is not
uh and if as councilwoman says that
needs to be extended we obviously would
need to anticipate that in um
dealing with uh that point of connection
on to uh silver street i just wondered
if we could just be clear that up whilst
we're whilst we're having the
conversation i suppose
that was a question that was a question
for the agent if i'm if there's any
doubt about it so
yeah so
i mean there are lockable butlers
prepared to propose a footpath cycle way
to allow emergency active access if
necessary i don't know there's a need
necessary for
a dropping of the the grass seems to be
level with the road but obviously there
would need to be an access created we'd
have to agree the visibility's place
with highways um
so understood but if we've got traffic
speed slowed down through a tro in this
area
and i don't know that's necessarily been
on highways radar but if we've got
emergency vehicles potentially egressing
and accessing out here it seems the
sensible thing to do to make sure we've
covered that base as we go
i was just checking my reading of the
drawing that this sits at the end of a
speed table effectively around the head
of that cul-de-sac
and without getting the highway plans
out um
then i'm not entirely sure but in terms
of the tro removing the speed limit it
didn't form part of the outline consent
we've sort of followed that and it
hasn't been asked for as part of this
application by county highways no but we
are here we are having this conversation
and this is a
this is an opportunity to discuss and
consider the issues and county's advice
is as all stakeholders out to the
planning authority it is advice um so to
that extent if you're proposing that we
have emergency vehicles use this it
would seem prudent to plan for them um
and that's what i'm trying to explore
because clearly we don't want to have a
development which even if an emergency
vehicle is using this causes any form of
risk to
other highway users in silver street so
i do think we're going to need to
explore that but i did want to pick up
on the point that councillor william had
risen it's a good one
obviously if the roads are not adopted
you've talked about adoption of the
management company for the surface water
drainage arrangements
uh presumably we'll need to uh achieve
some resolution around management of
highways because it's quite a
considerable extent of highway it's not
it's not a small development of five
dwellings off a private drive we're
dealing with quite a length of uh
road and that needs to be maintained
managed and uh
all of the swale facilities kept
available so that it drains freely and
doesn't become uh in deteriorating
condition so i don't know what your
sense of proposals for that are so in
terms of surface water drainage the
intention would be to have that adopted
um
so
um that would be you know managed by by
the adopting authority
and we did submit a management strategy
as part of the the planning application
which obviously has been through the the
county highway authority and we've had a
sort of ongoing conversation with them
to overcome their comments as they've
arisen
highways um
at the moment um i don't think it's 100
resolved as to um definitely whether the
road is or isn't going to be adopted if
it's not then yes it would be managed by
the management company
okay but at the moment if we if we're
looking at a planning position and
granting it we need to take a decision
that reflects
what we understand of that position and
either we impose a condition which
manages that so that we have comfort
that uh the conditioned state of the
road is appropriate
for the duration of the lifetime of the
development
or we you know get resolution that it's
going to intend to be adopted so um i
think it will be useful to settle that
and it doesn't have to happen in this
committee but i think it's an important
point that council councilwellum uh
raises
so uh
just as a as a piece of conversation in
an informal meeting i'd welcome your
confirmation the position on that as
soon as you can give that
thank you
so i think phil that's one for your list
i would suggest is it
yes well it's either a condition or it
isn't a condition i think is the answer
at the moment i'm not really very sure
i think what we know is there doesn't
seem to be a proposal to adopt it which
would seem to suggest to me we need a
management
solution
which will give comfort to the community
and everybody else involved
thank you very much
um
so that's mr isabel councillor stringer
thank you
just on this there's been much
discussion about the silver street end
of this and rightly so just want to
clarify a couple of things there is a
significant difference in height between
this site and silver street
uh it is somewhere near a meter
so
it was put out there there wasn't there
is a significant difference what i don't
quite understand is why the opportunity
what why are we
putting a new entrance in the middle of
a hedge also to clarify on a very not
straight section of road this has got
bends going the wrong way for an access
it's got bends
sort of going backwards from your access
so you're going to need to take out an
awful lot of ancient hedge to get any
visibility at all there
why on earth is this cycleway and
emergency vehicle way
not coming in from the existing access
which is right where the national speed
limit changes to 30 mile an hour and
it's on the
uh on the inside of a bend so you'd have
perfect visibility in both directions
i i really don't if you look on page 296
and you see the lagoon
uh bottom left of that lagoon we're
proposing to plant a hedge to stop up an
old access into that field that seems to
me to be a complete missed opportunity
you could leave the hedge exactly where
it is
treat that as a boundary and you've
already got an access opened up that
could be your footway and emergency
vehicle entrance i i don't know why
that's not being done and you wouldn't
have to move the speed limit because
it's right on the speed limit change
just before the agent answers that
counsellor stringer um i wrote down
right at the beginning when we saw the
photograph of the original access that
it was a sort of a muddy track at the
moment and that the moat was to the
right of it and i wrote a question down
because i hadn't quite tweaked um
excess traffic might
displace the boat
um i just wondered if that
you know if you've got rumbling traffic
going past the moat on that area it's
just a thought i i may be talking out of
place but do you see where i'm coming
from you know you've got traffic going
no i don't understand what you mean how
do you well you can
put up a picture of the um
the access and then
i'm talking about the access on to
silver street
i thought you were talking nobody need
the mo no there's nowhere near the
moment ah i beg your pardon
ah thank you pardon sorry sorry sorry
yeah i said yeah you're mixing up your
water vessels
yeah okay sorry
we'd like to answer andrew's question i
beg your pardon i'm sorry yeah because
if we can just to look at that if you
can put that service road that close to
that lagoon it could easily bend around
that corner of that lagoon and use the
existing driveway in that bottom left
corner i see what you're getting no need
to change the speed limit leave the
hedge alone
we're happy to to look at that the
parameters followed
the original outline consent because the
original intention
was to
submit reserve matters under the
original outline consent but the layout
changes that um
we wanted to make to remove parking
courts and slightly changed the
alignment of the internal road running
through the site
meant that it wasn't um
a small change and we needed a whole new
application but we're more than happy to
to review that side of things if that's
you know what what um members would like
us to do
so so
i think the good news there chairman is
that
you've got the opportunity to amend the
application without any of the formality
of deferral and doing all these things
because actually this is part and parcel
of what if members feel this way about
it this is part and parcel of giving me
a steer involved
and i'm just looking at
the delights of google street view and i
see the point that council string is
making it's just literally in the
national speed limit but if you're still
doing the national speed limit at that
point
you'll have to rapidly decelerate i fear
yeah
they need signs that do you know
i don't know if they do them here where
they say 30 in a few minutes 30 and a
couple of hundred yards 30 or whatever
maybe that's something that highways can
consider anyway
good points
um keith council welum you you'd like to
add to this please can i can i refer to
an answer that miss holland gave about
the adoption of the surface water
drainage i understood miss holland said
that
the surface water drainage would be
adopted
am i right
yes
so the adoption of the surface water
drainage does that include the balancing
part
we would include it would include the
surface water features
so my my concerns about
the um
the de-silting and and all the checks on
the on the de-watering and so on
they
they they are no longer concerns then if
you're saying that because
anglian water or the internal drainage
board or whoever
as the responsible authority they would
carry out the checks that they thought
were necessary am i right yes i think
i've lost my video but i am still here
if you cut if i'm frozen or you can't
see me i am still here but um yes they
would be um responsible for the surface
water drainage
that's that's absolutely brilliant news
yeah i'm really pleased about that
because it is always a concern
that residents are left with having to
look at balance clean out balancing
ponds and and the like thank you very
much
and that's very useful i actually wrote
down as um she said and it says looking
to have it adopted and i put anglia
water question mark so good points
raised well done thank you
right um so we now move on to our ward
members if you'd like to speak my my
speaking note says we don't have anyone
else to speak but i see councillor eben
would you like to speak please
um thank you chair but i wonder if um
councillor welling wanted to
um
go with the parish with because he was
going to do something after the parish
council i'm not sure if you want to okay
yeah okay and then council william can
continue with his district bit if that's
necessary thanks okay right okay
counselor welcome have a go that way
around then thank you
thank you very much yeah this is from
the parish council
further to our previous comments on the
redesigned application
we should like to repeat our concerns
over the uniformity of the design and
appearance of the properties
old newton like most other villages in
suffolk has grown slowly in size over
several hundred years
with this gradual growth the residential
properties have shown a wide variety of
shapes designs and finishes and this has
helped give the village its own
character
this is a large development for the
village so
to so to help it blend in with what we
already have we feel it is most
important to have more variety in the
design and appearance
as agreed by the report from the
heritage department page 202 paragraph
two
and the report from historic england
and conservation page
243 paragraph three
while we welcome the inclusion of some
rendered finishes with different colors
the plan doesn't state
the proportion of these
we also welcome the inclusion of some
decorative brickwork to some of the
properties however we are still left
with an overwhelming uniformity of house
design and appearance
and should like to see a variety of roof
lines
which could include some dormer windows
a variety of fenestration and porch
shapes and roof pitches
we hope the planning committee
understand these concerns and act
accordingly
so that's the parish
council um
so yeah thank you for the opportunity to
speak as one of the lord one of the ward
members
um
yeah i'm pleased to see the table
drawing which is indicating that the
poll and the stay will be relocated into
the development site this is absolutely
essential to ensure that there's a 1.5
meter footweight width along there
so that's that's good news
um
i'm still concerned about the safer
route to school or a safe route to
school
i believe there should be some
requirement for improvement to the route
to the primary school
church road as we've already heard has
no footwear for much of its length and
off-road routes are impassable when the
public footpath is wet and slippery
a safe all-weather route needs to be
provided off-road or alongside church
road
street lighting
there are no details given of street
lighting proposals
light should be eco-friendly with sharp
cut-offs to keep horizontal spread to a
minimum
home security lighting should be kept to
a minimum in terms of power and spread
of light
it may be worthwhile putting something
in in the conditions to that effect
um
yeah flooding and flooding and drainage
i was concerned about and residents have
expressed concern
about the the amount of water that's
going to come out of the balancing pond
and it's going to find its way into a
ditch
and they are concerned
that because of the difference in levels
and the the the the ditch itself
that there could be a flow of water
into into silver street and onto
actually onto the road
um i'm glad now we that the business
about the holding objection from floods
and water that's been resolved so i
don't need to refer to that
and i was pleased to see some wildflower
planting
uh rather than all grass which is my
often moan frequently and kept short
i'm not sure whether all of the areas
that are shown in that particular color
are going to be wild flower or whether
there is still going to be a proportion
of um
of grass that's that's cut frequently
i'd like that to be kept to a minimum
and i wonder would it be possible to
provide benches and play equipment in
the area at the front of the site
because that would be attractive for
young people and it will save
the children having to cross the main
road in order to get to play equipment
and my only other concern was around the
maintenance of the retention pod which i
think now is completely sorted out
so i'm grateful for that i'm grateful
for the opportunity to make my comments
thank you very much
i'm happy to answer questions if there
are any
or perhaps you'd like to hear councillor
eben first and then we'll both answer
any questions
thank you
i'll go ahead um
thank you keith my fellow
award counsellor
and thanks again to rose for the
presentation um which i think was was
very helpful
many issues on around this site have
been raised by the parish council
residents have i want to focus on just a
few pedestrian safety
housing styles and gardens flooding and
the landscape there's a couple of points
that i'll duplicate with my fellow ward
councillor just to stress these
particular points
and firstly please can the committee
ensure there will be a footwear along
the eastern side of the site connecting
it to the footwear at faulconers avenue
the highway as i've said in the
questions the highway verge along
finlingham road is extremely narrow at
the point where it meets um faulkner's
avenue and a full-width footwear must be
made um despite the obstacles of
telegraph poles and the like and this is
very important for both residents of the
site to access village amenities but
also for existing old newton residents
to access the new wildflower open space
on the site
the county response on the primary
school is that it is a safe walking
distance
and as rose has shown in the
presentation the distance from the
housing on the site to the school is
about a mile by road but over half of
this is on a road with no footwear
as she has noted
the community's been working really hard
to get a safe route to school from the
village to the school including across
the fields
doing the which does the final path to
the school but obviously in the winter
that's very wet and muddy and as part of
this application we would ask for
funding to improve and develop this
route
comment has been made regarding the
bland housing styles and i know the
officer comments on this
while the neighboring estate falcons
avenue is of a particular 20th century
design rookery farm is obviously a
traditional suffolk farm house rendered
and with flint walled barns and walls
however the buildings on the western
side side of the development on silver
street are a mix of farm cottages and
other housing types
there are a variety of styles in the
village and this development should
reflect that not just the
absolute neighboring housing estate
and on the subject of housing there are
some very small gardens such as plots 2
3 4 7
20 and 22 but particularly three which
is on the furthest on the east of the
site and 22 on the furthest west which
is for three bedroom homes very tiny
gardens and i think this is particularly
important as there is no play equipment
proposed on the site
um just as a minor issue we do need to
be assured that the developers fully
aware of the boundaries of the existing
properties in falcone avenue as have
been some change to those and their
access
and view
backing onto the field there
residents have got concerns regarding
flooding onto silver street the rest of
the site and i know the recent answers
regarding responsibility and hope that
this will therefore not be an issue
and finally as i've raised in questions
please can we limit how much of the old
established hedge along silver street on
the western side of the site is removed
as much as and so that as much as
possible is retained and this is vital
both for wildlife but also to retain the
rural character around this site thanks
very much and happy to take any
questions thank you chair
thank you for that rachel there is in
the conditions there play equipment
details um and i think it's very
important that um you know that's
for the planners to make sure that it's
put forward so i did just manage to
notice that one
right any questions for cancer ebon
please
no i i think
the two of you have done admirably there
um
right well
we sort of seem to be having a debate as
we go along which i think is quite
useful
um so for those people who haven't
spoken yet um who would like to
say something now about what we have
before as please counselor mueller thank
you yes um thank you very much chair yes
i found a really interesting application
listening to everything that everyone
has said
and the one of the things that actually
pleases me most of this application is
the fact that every single property is
going to be fitted with an air source
heat pump
and i think we should actually really
welcome this because on many um
applications we've looked at over the
last few years we've often raised this
particular issue so i think that's
really excellent
i like the idea of the adoption of the
balancing pond etc and also the fact
that officers are going to look at the
uplift in the design i think that's also
really important but on the whole yeah
really good thank you
thank you councillor muller
um councillor castin
thank you madam chairman
um
yeah i completely agree with council
mueller there um
i think the um air source is brilliant
the um adoption of the suds is exactly
how we should be um doing things the
frontage is good on this um
development as well but i can't help
being a bit confused by this three meter
strip up the north
side it just seems to me that um
any benefit to um
biodiversity or anything else um will be
completely outweighed by the the
the less the you know the the burden on
residents with the maintenance
or the lack of security to the back
gardens of the houses i don't i don't
see a huge amount of benefit it's got a
um
it's it's potentially got a hedge or a
um
a fence six foot
high
you know from the south side it's not
gonna it's not gonna get a lot of sun
it's um it's either gonna have to be
maintained in a costly way or it's gonna
go to brambles or um
or something else um i don't know what
other councils think about that but
i i understand the issues with the safe
journey to school obviously this is some
i don't think the developer has a lot of
control over that otherwise the um the
village does have some good
um sustainable qualities there and um
good provisions for um houses so um
yeah i'll
i'll i'll see if anyone else is um
as confused as i am about the three
meter strip and um
yeah and but um
generally i think it's a good design
it's a good layout
um and it's a sense you know it's a
sensible place to put it
um thank you for that um i'm just
looking at the conditions and everything
i wonder if we could flag that as one of
the things
um for a steer for that you're
disappearing
with my camera look at this sliding away
um i wonder if it's something that we
could have um you know give philip a
steer on to sort of bottom it out to
make sure
um that um it doesn't become a bramble
nightmare i know what it's like with my
little space that i've got you've got to
keep them down but um what's philip got
to say on that
it occurs to me that some of those back
gardens are only
you know a few meters
long i just think it would be much
better to extend the back gardens and
not have that um there's the
biodiversity from a back garden is as
good as a um strip
yeah you put a hedgehog running and all
sorts of things yeah exactly you plant
flowers there's a lot of benefits to a
um a
garden that a resident looks after and i
just don't think that's of any benefit
whatsoever but yeah sorry i'll
we'll ask philip what he thinks
we can ask him to find out and sort it
out yeah i mean uh i think i'd start by
going going to what we've got in terms
of ecological advice um and
how how essential this is as part of
that to be locked into things i mean
from my perspective
um you know wild untidy areas actually
can be quite good for biodiversity you
know they create corridors and um
as i think council williams said earlier
neatly bone stuff isn't necessarily
uh i can sometimes be a bit like the
desert really so um i think there's a
bit of balance i understand what council
castle is talking about and uh there is
a balance between what's provided to
garden space for individual properties
and making sure there is um you know an
appropriate route for um
uh ecological species to make the best
of a space which is away from where the
humans are and i suspect that's possibly
the the opportunity to look at
but certainly in terms of this committee
i mean i think if if that's a steer that
you want that looked at then um and
that's within within the realms of
possibility to do and to
come to a conclusion over so that we
achieve something that is
uh
not an untidy area is appropriately
managed for the long term and uh
nonetheless is
uh not a not a conflict for for amenity
for people who for the future occupants
of this development so
i've got all of those things as as you
know points that cause the cast is
concerned that it'd be interesting to
hear how others feel about that point
and thank you for that and also thank
you for raising it councillor casten i
mean again it does say landscape an
ecological management plan amendments it
says on the conditions so i think we can
give phil um a steer
to to make improvements where possible
so
that that would be my view on it but i
hope that comforts you
yeah
right then we'll move on to councillor
norris if we may please
thank you chair um
i think we've had a very full discussion
actually on this application
i'd like to thank the officer for the
presentation which is
very
comprehensive
this application looks to be very well
conditioned on pages 216 and 217 of the
papers
and i think the ward members brought up
some
interesting points
i'm particularly interested in
councillor stringer's suggestions
regarding the link to silver street i
think that's certainly very well worth
exploring
subject to a few tweakings if this were
a normal um planning meeting as it were
i would be
minded to support this
application so thank you that's all i
wish to say
thank you councillor norris very useful
um and i agree with all of what you've
said really um councillor mayor
thanks chair yeah i think
this um
development has a lot to commend it a
lot of um good aspects
i do
struggle to see
why if all of the drainage is going to
be adopted the surfaces wouldn't be um i
know that's still being discussed but um
i will urge parties there
to achieve that adoption i'm sure the
residents will be delighted with that um
i was also delighted to hear there is
play equipment that open area he is
crying out for play equipment
um councillor stringer's point three the
um the entrance to the west silver
streets makes eminent sense to me and i
support that
i also support parish council
um i think
the design is
he's poor in terms of its aesthetics you
know
um
i i
get the impression it's you know small
boxes that look all the same all in a
line is not what a village looks like
and i think
we may be too far down the road to
change that but it would have been good
to have different properties
interspersed um down that street scene
to show
far more variety and i think the parish
counts are absolutely right
um a little bit of render of different
color a few brick um details
may help but i i don't think we're going
to overcome that fundamental issue that
it lacks variety and that i think is an
opportunity missed
if we were voting it'd be an interesting
one
sit on the fence
thank you
or all the strip down the back of the
houses that's interesting that is
interesting
um
moving on we've got um councillor mellon
please
uh yeah thank you chair um
[Music]
take my hand down right um yeah so i
think there's quite a lot about this
development that i like um
the um
i like the the raised tables which i
think will all sort of slow uh traffic
coming onto the site and moving through
it um
the connectivity
is also a good aspect um and i do like
um cancer stringer's suggestion that we
bend that sort of cycle way around the
edge of the um
the suds area and take it into the
um
silver street right next to the last
house there at the moment
um
obviously this site is the other end of
the village from the school and that
does present a problem
um
in terms of uh you know people walking
or cycling from this site to school it
does seem particularly unlikely
um
in the winter months uh when when they
can't use that footpath across the
fields
um
so we we obviously do need to maximize
the connectivity we can gain here and
there's just that concern um having
looked at finningham road
on google
um street view
the
the foot bath does peter out
um
at the end of falconer avenue it just
tapers down to nothing and then you've
got this very narrow grass verge until
we get to the edge of this site so i
don't know quite what can be done about
that um
that that really does need to be a
proper
pedestrian link there but i'm not quite
sure what we can achieve given that it's
off-site and there's also not very much
room there so i'd just like to welcome a
bit of clarification on that
in terms of the
um the style of the development um
obviously that end of
of old newton does have
um a lot of houses that were built at a
certain period when sort of uniformity
was was put in
um and they all look the same and it's
not particularly
um
pleasing so so any improvement in this
new
um
this new area would be great
having said that um
[Music]
you can often end up with
modern designs where there's a kind of
hot potch of different
things thrown all together
um
i grew up in marshall and you have to go
and look at the new village there to see
that in in action so i i i do like some
uniformity of design um and if we can
tweak that with you know various
elements um as described and
um i see we're still trying to improve
that i think that that's acceptable
um
i do welcome those improved
details um but yeah i think the main
concern for me is is that sort of
pedestrian safety aspect and the
connections
um i think that silver street if we can
mend that that'll be fine i'd still have
some questions about the fining and road
end of things thank you thank you very
much um
councillor stringer
thank you chair
uh yeah
lots to uh be of interest here not
i'm going to tackle with the the bits
and hopefully get some clarity
the connectivity of the site to the
school uh councillor wellum the parish
council everyone else is perfectly
correct
um
to walk to the school
with the current road conditions and
field conditions because you have to
cross three fields
uh to to walk to school because you
can't walk in the road it's way too
dangerous
you have to walk across three fields and
they're impossible
with the current state of fields so
but but we did not put any conditions on
the original
approval of the outline
to insist on offsite works to make that
path
better
so i go back to my original
theme about quality of original
outline decisions and i'll leave that
there
um
in terms of uh
if we could
ecologically save more of that hedge by
amending the
that silver street entrance i think
that's a good thing to be able to do it
will also bend that entrance closer to
the services so if people were going to
walk to the village shop using that
entrance or cycle there or go anywhere
else
it pushes you closer to the to those
services by by short amount so it may
mean more people use that rather than
jump in a car
getting back to the design
i'm i'm slight at times i'm slightly
struggling with with some of that
because
uh as councilor mellon said if you try
and introduce
almost a false randomization it looks
contrived uh and one person's uniformity
could be another person's theme
uh
i don't have a problem with
uninterrupted roof lines frankly
i i'm surrounded by roof lines here and
i've got two that are
in excess of 15 meters long each of them
uh they look fine the one that's got
loads of dormers in the modern one is
constantly having to have maintenance
done to it because it keeps letting
water in so i think
over the lifetime of the of of the
building a a sharp crisp roof line is
probably not a bad thing in terms of
long-term maintenance
and there are and and to say that there
needs more elements of design in the
elevations there's there's brick coins
there's banding in there there's porches
in there uh the parachutes ask for a
variety of roof pitches there are a
variety of roof pitches there's 30
degrees it's 45 degrees uh there is
actually some variety there so i'm i'm
slightly
struggling to see how this
how this isn't what you would have
expected
in some way uh outline stage what were
you expecting to see when the outline
permission was approved in terms of
design if it needed although some of the
indicative drawings out on stage were
almost
all
wooden eco homes which would have looked
very modern and very different
but if the officers want to
as we said earlier trying to improve
the quality of the materials uh
be our guest but i i think on balance if
i had to vote on this i'll be voting
in favor if i could amend that entrance
save more of that hedge and perhaps
introduce some line rendering to to
soften that perhaps that's all i need to
say thank you chad
thank you very much indeed councillor
stringer um if there's no one else to
speak i'll say a few words i'm not going
to repeat much of what's been said
um i've jotted down as i've been going
through as i like the mix of housing
that they've got there
i like the fact that heating and air
source heat pumps
are throughout um i'm afraid i did write
the design is a bit boring but um i
think i hate using this expression we
are where we are and i think councillor
stringer's suggestion of a few
color
patches here and there and what have we
might do do the trick
um
and uh
yes the the alteration if that can
happen
around the the um attenuation pond and
to save the hedgerow would be useful
and anything outside the um site i'm
afraid we can't really impose anything
now i think there's quite a lot of
conditions on there that
[Music]
the chief planning officer can go away
and get his teeth into um so i would be
approving this
um so i don't know philip if you want to
just sort of run through the issues and
how you see the steer that we've offered
you today
thank you chairman um yeah so
the recommendation um contained various
conditions and it included effectively
an expectation to set some amendments i
think what i've come out of this meeting
with the steer over is that there's more
work to be done on some of those things
i'm conscious that uh the developers
have a time imperative for grant funding
on this site so i've i've got that in my
mind so it will need some timely work by
uh by the applicant
and by ourselves to bring that about um
but in essence i think just to to run
through these in the sequence of those
i've got them um certainly i think we
need to look closely at materials and uh
what design opportunities there are to
tweak what we have
and that's both materials in relation to
the buildings and i think in relation to
the surfacing of areas because they can
sometimes be just as important for
uh forming character and managing access
uh
in an appropriate way
and on that point of access i'm also
conscious that um
there's a discussion about the
relocation of the uh emergency entrance
point i think by relocating you would
also discourage
what i would describe as the kind of
anti-social usage by
motorized wheeled users perhaps of um
of things like uh cycleways so i think
there is some benefit to that and to
look at that
in a revised form skirting the edge of
the suds feature so that it exits
without punching a hole in
the established hedge but comes out
closer to the 30 mile an hour
speed limit which
i think
is an opportunity to explore and may
well create a more interesting walking
route if i'm honest um in all weathers
and we did talk a bit about um
walking places in all weathers and we
are in the winter where walking across
any kind of landscaped area is always a
bit of a challenge if you've got a pair
of wellington so i'm i'm conscious
that's i think an opportunity that i do
want to actively explore with uh
with the applicant um
i i will also take away the question
that council caston had regarding the
area to the rear of the dwellings
um i've got no mind around where that
takes us but uh he raised the question i
think it's reasonable enough for us to
explore that further and to
see whether
that takes us as a conclusion
and
broadly speaking i think most of those
points then chairman are
sufficient for me the only other one is
bearing in mind that we started i think
with council while i'm querying the
adoption status of the highway
and not the um
not the um the suds feature i think we
still have an open question about that
and the extent to which we as officers
may or may need not need to put
conditions on to manage that for the
long term chairman and i think uh castle
string has got his hand up
yes
um i think that sums up most of the
things that i've got written down as
well
councillor stringer yeah just want to
make a little point about that that
three meter and
councillor casten's thing
the
lot of that is actually trees native
trees to be planted
and and
and i'm mindful of that if that three
meat strip became part of a garden
that the trees would probably suffer at
the benefit of the trampolines
so
there is there is that balance to be
struck but if it was just a hedge that
was on the north side of a fence it is
going to suffer but if they are native
trees they will probably be okay
the wrong side of the light of a fence
uh and and and it's probably better that
fenced off because it will remain
in the gardens i think we'll have death
by a thousand cuts
i think you're absolutely right on that
actually um uh
i had i must admit i'd forgotten it was
going to be trees so we'll leave that
with um philip to ponder then would you
be happy with that
yes i i think from my perspective
there's a there's a question to get to
the bottom of but it's um
you know my only instinct is it serves a
useful purpose rather than to try and uh
change something there chairman but
we'll see yeah yeah yeah and with the
time constraints that could prove um
problematic okay then so we've finished
that one now it's 20 to one now i'm with
anyone on this um we have
sort of um two more applications are we
quite happy to keep going or do we want
a five minute break
um
what does anybody want to do on this
because the two of them are probably
linked together in in in some way
sorry chairman if i may i might need a
five minute break before i start
presenting if that helps
so we'll have a five minute break and
then we'll just go through it i think
if everyone's happy with that five
minutes then thank you
well welcome back thank you very much
indeed
we now have our next agenda case um
reference dc 2104
and vincent priest
yes peggy pardon we'll present the case
and um if you'd like to do that now
please thank you very much
thank you jay good after members i love
seeing members i'm just gonna make sure
i've pressed the right button to get the
presentation up
and hopefully
that is now on your screens
yeah good let's
let's proceed so this is a reserved
matters application and uh
what we're looking at today are
appearance layout scale
and landscaping access has previously
been agreed under the outline
planning permission
unfortunately
nothing is happening
on the screen it's completely frozen
so we're just
whatever it was is now gone
as before this presentation is merely uh
a supplement to the report
representations and other material
considerations so let us proceed with
the discussion
on the screen at the moment is the
form of of buildings and arrangement of
buildings expected
from the outline planning permissions
that exist on this site i will be
talking to you this afternoon about
units one and two which are shown with
the red arrow and my colleague avril
will follow me
to discuss the details for unit
6. great blakenum is a key service
center
in terms of general location
close to junction 51
on the a14
just to the south of the
what was known as the snoasus site and
is now known as the valley ridge
site accessed via the b-triple 1 3 and
the brownford road
the outline of port 1 as a business park
is shown in the light green
this is
another development within
freeport east which members will know
is very important economically
not just to the east of england but also
to the district
um
freeport east is one of eight freeports
in england
this particular site
is recognized by the government as
a custom site
it passes all the necessary tests and is
a key part of the jigsaw in terms of
the region's response to the need to
attract inward investment and get goods
moving
in terms of constraints there are very
few
we have footpath 13 running across the
top also known as blue barn lane
the site
shown in the crosstalk there's very
little by way of
constraints
on this site
we have a very short section of
graphics which will
help members get an idea of what port
one will look like when it's finished so
let's just press the
the button so we're going up branford
road that's unit one
the design has slightly changed since
this gcgi was made
on the left is unit 2
accessed from the new state road known
as black acre road
that's the new spine road
and there are to be warehouses left and
right
the building on the left has
slightly modified in the building is
closer to the
the road but the principle is the same
you'll also notice the very distinctive
um
color and patterning of the buildings
this has previously been agreed by
members we had a lot of discussion about
which way the banding should work
the committee
decided this is
the appropriate form of banding
because it helps disguise this
development from long views
against
the existing developments
so you can clearly see it is
focused on the distribution of of goods
heavily
predicated on
imports from felixstowe
and heritage
inside the warehouses there are
racks
nine
nine high filling
the space
both
the both buildings that you look at this
afternoon are already pre-let
as have been the other two units within
port one that one is now occupied once
under construction
we are told that demand for this sort of
logistics space is very high which is
good for
the district it's good for jobs it's
good for the economy
it's probably also good for the
council's gateway 14 site
just to the west
in this shot you start to see some of
the
ecological
and habitat
benefits that have been included and
they were all seen previously when we
were looking at an outline planning
application
so in terms of this site
work is currently underway on that
access the cycleway link
that was included
as a highway improvement will be
completed by easter this year
on that junction to what is now black
acre road
uh actually access itself is due to be
completed in january so within a few
weeks of this year
included in
the highway works are
cycleway improvements i know this is
something that many members previously
wanted to be assured would be happening
those works are
underway if we look at the blue dot
that will just illustrate
not only will the cycleway go into the
the new logistics part but it also goes
northwards along the brownford road
this is a very recent photograph showing
the progress being made with formation
of the the access
here we see in red
the actual site for plots one and two
so as i say unit 4 is completed and
occupied by company
fds that do a lot of work with online
trading
unit 3 is currently under construction
access to
plots one and two are separated
originally when this came in there was
one big access in the middle
which actually meant they could there
was no space for
landscaping so after discussion with the
applicants we've modified that the
highway authority are happy with this
this arrangement and it does allow us to
soften the frontage of the site by
adding some landscaping but also i draw
to your attention on the left of this
image
there is a
parking deck to provide two two levels
of parking and because of ground level
differences it's possible to drive
straight onto that deck from addison way
so we actually have three points of
entry to this site
for vehicles
in terms of how you get into the site
i've quickly
just shown you that a an articulated
lorry can swing into that site
safely it does the same to to get out
that has been approved by the highway
authority we've checked all the swept
paths or more accurately they have
so we're comfortable that that
arrangement works
the good news here is that uh
port one is a highly sustainable site
and i'm sure we'll hear from the
applicant when they have their
opportunity just how committed they are
to pushing the boundaries of
green credentials on
business parks but to start with we'll
have 20 of the
spaces with ev
provided in terms of all the apparatus a
further 20 spaces 20 of spaces will be
provided with the full set of falsies
but at the moment they'll just have the
right connections
um so as soon as the switch is thrown
to take energy from the energy from
waste plant
we'll have 40 of those spaces we'll
actually have the charging apparatus
provided so
if we quickly look the green flashing
dots are where we would have
full apparatus from day one
blue flashing dots are where we would
have the full apparatus
as soon as the tap is turned
in terms of energy from the plant on the
other side of brownford road
context
i mean plot one is immediately adjacent
to the energy from waste plant you can
see the scale and mass of the energy
from waste plant in this photograph
again
a very
a very attractive i would say
contemporary
award-winning
modern design
this is the front of the site and as you
can see at the moment it is already
a construction site
most of this whole site is now looks
like this where there are earth movers
and all kinds of activity going on
representing a huge investment within
the district
there you can see the framework of unit
3
going up with unit 4 in the background
in terms of
elevations
the elevations reflect
a sort of a house style that you have
now previously approved on at least two
occasions this would be known as the
sort of port one house style
with the horizontal banding you can see
on the left how the difference in levels
means that we can utilize deck parking
and access to the building for
pedestrians
in terms of the roof plan single span
roof very shallow pitched
and the elevation i'll just turn it
around you can see how the elevations
tie in with those roof plans
in terms of cross section here's a cross
section through what are units three and
four so previously
you allowed some cut and fill and cut
and fill is a feature of this site
to create levels but you can see
units three and four are significantly
below the height of
the energy from waste plant
in terms of
units one and two again they are
significantly lower than the
energy from waste plant they are
comparable with the previous permissions
that you have granted in terms of total
building height
and if we superimpose
the existing buildings
in their position in front of units one
and two you can see
they are compatible
again
these are elevations typical of what
we've already approved
in terms of this elevation on the edison
wave frontage obviously there's ground
floor access to the parking
but because of the difference in levels
access to the deck deck is a raised
position and vehicles
will drop down onto the spine road
so it's quite a
clever use of the difference in levels
to ensure that we've
enhanced and increased the levels of
parking
building heights i thought this would be
useful
because you can see from these the black
18.9 and 18.4
in terms of units 2 and 1 respectively
they are
in keeping with what we have either
approved or are already expecting
so there isn't anything here that's
going to stick out like a sore thumb in
comparison to what you've already
approved
in terms of floor plans
essentially
on this on unit one we have two
relatively small mezzanine floors
the rest is floor-to-ceiling
racks of shelving
to
ensure that there is maximum capacity
for goods
unit two very similar
office and mezzanine
two floors is a large void space on the
ground again for logistical
activities
in terms of jobs whilst
this isn't necessarily a matter to be
that's relevant to the details it's
worth just recalling that because these
are now pre-led we know that all in all
this will create 145 jobs
which would mean the running total so
far on port 1 is 600 jobs
and the business rate receipt from units
1 2 3 4 and 6.
subject to reserve matters being
approved and implemented is in the
region of 1.58 million pounds
per annum
landscaping
we have
enhanced and increased the areas for
landscaping but members will recall that
the
port one development includes a large
area of new woodland to the south it
includes
large areas of new habitat creation so
this is a very small part of a much
bigger jigsaw
but we have ensured that the northern
and eastern boundaries will be well
landscaped
because they are prominent public
frontages but we've also ensured that
the
more internalized spine road frontage
now has
softening planting
again drainage is not a matter for you
to think about today it's dealt with by
condition but just to show you that what
is being uh
proposed are large
crate systems underground that will
retain surface water
the drainage strategy for this site has
already been agreed
and the details will be the subject of a
submission of
detail under a condition
members will recall previously the
sensitive area is the boundary between
this site and what is the blakenum
estate
and on the screen this is a thick dense
deep area of
woodland plantation
so as you can see the red dot in terms
of units one and two that is as far
removed from that sensitive area as we
can get it within the port one
development we have no concerns about
adverse impact on
heritage assets
or even in terms of landscape impact
in terms of sustainability i'm sure the
applicant will be able to tell us more
about
the detail but as i say we are expecting
100 of the energy to come from
the energy from waste plants so that
means there's a sustainable source of
energy
the company is committed to installing
pv
on on the roofs and that will run
most of the internal lighting if not all
of the internal lighting in all the
buildings
and other parts of the
fabric
the company did commit an outline stage
to delivering electric powered shuttle
bus services for employees that will
pick up
employees from a range of visit villages
around the site
that
electric powered shuttle bus system will
be triggered by completion of the unit
that's currently under construction so
we are a matter of
months away from
what i think will be the first
shuttle bus system on a business park
that we've seen and that will be
electric powered
so again that's pushing the
boundaries it's raising the bar so that
we can
begin to insist on such things on
similar developments elsewhere
you've seen the level of ev charging
that's that will be delivered the
company is committed to
having electric powered forklifts across
across the site
so no more diesel
chugging
forklifts
i've already explained the commitment to
habitat creation and woodland creation
something else that
clearly comes up from
a logistics park being located
within our district so close to the
ports
potentially this will mean a lot less
hgv movements
up and down the country
i believe there will be a significant
saving in
carbon footprint and mileage
because
traditionally
the large
national warehouses were in the midlands
so
containers coming in from felix though
would usually trundle along the
a14
to the midlands where the main storage
areas were and then they would all come
trundling back to be redistributed to
the regions what we have here in terms
of gateway 14 port 1 and other sites
within
gateway east are the
much more localized
facilities
which is ideal in terms of the change to
the whole nature in retailing across the
country with the prominence of online
retailing that has sprung up
fairly recently
so
another interesting feature and it's
it's unique to this particular
site and plot plot one
has been pre-let to a company
called messina hembree
and their entire business is
online driven and what they do is
they recycle
second-hand
pre-loved
designer branded and vintage clothing
so
this is
extending the life of clothing
rather than going out and importing more
new
new clothes so that whole warehouse
there's enough business that they have
they have tapped into to fully utilize a
building of this this size so i think
that's
something that members would be
interested in in perhaps seeing if we
get to the point of
approving reserve matters through the
chief planning officer and then this
building being implemented as i say it
will be implemented because they're both
pre-led so in terms of the
recommendation what we are suggesting
uh
to the chief planning officer and
suggesting to you as
councillors at this meeting is that we
would support the reserved matters
um
with conditions set out in in the
reporting and the others that you may
wish to suggest to the chief
thank you chair
i'm muted
thank you very much indeed um i can see
hands going up to have questions for you
so
um councillor castin um please do ask
your questions
do you want me to remove the um
presentation here
that might be actually quite useful um
vincent okay
for me um
well i really want to try and get my
head around this site layout plan and
where the um
where the people are going to drive in
where they're going to park where
they're going to walk through into the
um
into the um
warehouse
and also where that vintage clothing
part is where the um customers will go
to
hey please yeah let me just take you
back
let's go back a bit further
but there's quite a few slides
there we are so unit one
here this is the branford road
so to the right of where the cursor is
is the energy from waste
plant
so this is the new access that's under
construction
this is this is what will be known as
black acre road
so pedestrian the pedestrian
entry point for
these are
this one it's
it's here
and then this one it's
here
so
this says the
footway
this will also be available to
cars for employees on the deck so you
come in at this higher deck level enter
the building at first floor into the
offices at first floor whereas on this
one you come in at ground floor
so this is the service access in here
and this is a service access
in here
and this road goes right down into the
rest of the
new port one development this is addison
way which links through to the existing
the older industrial estate
and as part of this scheme
i think it's unit 3 triggers then the
closure of addison way to hgvs
traveling in the northern direction
that was something the members wanted to
see they wanted to
reduce the amount of hgvs trundling
through
this
section and if we go back a few more
slides
counselor cast and we'll just put that
in a
in a wider context
yeah
so branford road as part of the previous
outline
i'll see it's all going
sorry council let's just
take it a little more gently
there will also be a new uh crossing
point to the north included in
now we've got to included in highway
improvements secured under the outline
so not only we do we get a three meter
wide pedestrian cycle and pedestrian
access along brantford way but it also
goes right into the heart of
this development
so it's
improving access
for both pedestrians and psych cyclists
and whenever it does have presentation
you'll see that that goes right to the
back of the
the site
and the crossing to the north actually
allows people
greater connectivity with
developments on the east side of
branford
brumford road all of that was secured
and outlined
there we are that's where i want to stop
and hold listed so you can see at the
moment
people come into the development through
edison
edison way this will be closed to hgvs
traveling north
soon this is a new junction
so you'd come along the 113
and you'd swing in left
part of those junction works
that are now
underwear and i expect to be finished in
the end of this month will mean that
vehicles coming out
then are forced to turn right
and that was something members wanted to
see and i know a number of members on
the committee and certainly council of
field it's part of a strategy to prevent
hgvs traveling northwards
along brantford through
branford so this will actually deliver
almost like traffic management that
means hgvs are restricted to
entry and access from the
a14 at junction 51
which should be much better for
residents living along brownford road
i don't know whether that uh
provides the clarification or i've
made it
more difficult
thank you very much but um so where are
the lorries going to turn because they
they go into that first one
within the site they can they can go in
forward gear and come out in forward
gear
all right okay they can yeah yeah
there's enough there's enough room
and it's been designed to allow an
articulated lorry to be able to turn and
enter and leave in forward gear there's
no prospect of anyone
reversing out with an hgv
yeah okay yeah no now i've got that
actually um and the um and the clothing
outlet
that's this one
here
and which part is it that that because
it's not is it is is it the way is it
the same entrance for the clothing
outlet
that's yeah yeah yeah that's their
entrance
there for v for hgvs pedestrians coming
here
on unit two
vehicles
hdvs come in there but pedestrians come
in there at first floor
so you saw
if you were employed there you'd be walk
you'd be entering the building half no
two-thirds one-third
yeah one-third of the way up but that's
because the level of the ground here in
that somewhere is much higher here than
it is
here
that's probably
two
let me just thank you
thank you
thank you very much james and uh richard
uh councillor mayor your turn please
thanks so much
vincent i have no wish to open um old
discussions that seemingly have gone off
sometime but can you just give me a
little more on why the dark line is at
the top of the building yes
ordinarily you might expect the
lighter color to be at the top
so that when you're viewing the building
against the sky
it it would merge naturally with the
colors in the
in the sky obviously we all know that
with the
english climate you don't always have
blue skies
and generally a light gray tends to
merge with a gray sky or a blue sky
better than the dark grey
but the sensitive viewing angles are
from the wider open countryside looking
back
against
the existing built form
and to help the building disappear into
those views
having the darker color at the top means
that you cannot see
a
well these are a
large scale
rectangular buildings if the lighter
color was at the top it would actually
appear more prominent
in the long views
actually having the darker color at the
top disguises it it just blends in with
the
built form when viewed from principally
the west and the
north
so i think when we had this last time we
said yes if you were right at the um
on the brantford road
it might you would see the
dark grey against the sky which might
not be
the natural
relationship you would expect but the
sensitive viewing is actually from the
countryside and we've ensured that it
just disappears into that
into the massive built form by having
the dark color at the top
thank you very much
i think that's an interesting question
but if you do go around the country you
do see that and it does actually work
it almost seems at odds but um it's a
good question to be
heard the reasoning so thank you
councillor stringer your turn now please
thank you chair uh just uh
following on from the
coloration oh obviously it depends what
color it is
uh if if you choose your color palette
like bacton transport at woolpit
business park and the color palette
starts with the color purple it doesn't
seem to fit in with anything at all at
any distance so
are we getting grays or are we getting
other
you know other colors
the
the other other issue
you mentioned solar panels were going to
be
uh
doing all of the lighting in the
building
um
do we
because the outline condition says at
least is it 10 of the
operation of the building should be from
somewhere but if they're using electric
forklifts and uh electric vehicles
etcetera um
does does just the lighting equate to 10
of the operation
and and if it does do we know how many
kilowatt hours or what percentage your
roof's getting covered thank you
thank you councillor stringer i start
with your second question first i
believe they've smashed the 10
percent right out of the
ballpark but we do have uh
a representative from the
the applicant
here this afternoon
i think i would much prefer him to tell
us specifically what their target is
because i feel certain he'll know
all the exact
numbers but i understand we've smashed
10 percent right out the ballpark
especially if we can get 100
energy from
the plant opposite
but i'm sure ben showed will tell us
exactly what those figures are in terms
of the grays you are right these will be
greys we're not looking at purples or
any
things i think if we just
quickly
shoot through there's a photograph where
you can actually see
the colors that we've approved and the
answer is we will continue
that's just a cgi bit
sorry
it's unfortunate because i can't
actually go back to the start
no
photographs coming up
there we are
so
that is the
the color scheme so we've almost got a
sort of a
slate battleship gray going down to a
dove grey
would be my
description
they are true greys if there is such a
thing
do you have any other questions
councillor stringer yeah
no chair that that no chair that was it
uh i just saw
some purple coloring on one of those
um that's all and and just as a point of
clarification the energy from the energy
from waste plant
uh less than 30 percent of that is
allowed to be called renewable uh by
defra or what was deferred okay because
it does burn a lot of unreasonable
sources yep
i think it's an interesting conversation
and uh i think unfortunately the one at
woolpid has got it wrong by putting
green on and then going to blue but we
don't need to go into that on this
application i think um all your
questions have been very useful and
vince has explained it
and councillor warboys thank you
thank you chair uh thank you vincent
that's you know it's quite an exciting
development this is lots of ways
especially the precedent is set for the
electric shuttle bus
um
i i've just got a query really about
from it's about the uh letters from
place services
uh about the sort of planting and where
we
are on that their last letter says
there's some queries raising play
services
that hasn't been um
answered uh my thoughts are you know
what what struck me was about the sort
of viability of some of the planting i
think queer is being raised
about whether
there's sufficient
land for them to sort of develop
properly
i know that across the site there's
a big biodiverse ecology scheme but i
think they were just concerned with this
the setting of this particular these
particular buildings
and i understand the
the point you're making and
because we have had a number of outlines
we've had a number of reserve matters
we've had some section 73
applications to vary permissions it is
becoming increasingly
complicated because most of the
ecological and landscape matters are
dealt with by conditions some of which
we've approved some of which we require
additional detail
to come forward and you're quite right
the majority of the ecological benefit
will come with
proposals that affect the wider
development so along the boundary with
the blakenam estate to the south of what
will be the development line where we're
getting a large area of
of new woodland in terms of this site we
are
purely trying to add some landscape to
the
black acre road frontage to add some
interest and softening we aren't
necessarily seeing that as a
as a key
wildlife corridor certainly behind the
building
we are and that's where the planting is
thicker but again
we've agreed the strategic landscaping
what we would expect to do is through
the chief planning officer when and if
he exercises
the authority
to approve these reserve matters we will
have very specific condition requiring
the exact detail so we want to know the
species we want another planting regime
we want to know the maintenance regime
but if you asked me i'd say candidly
this isn't the part of the site where we
are
creating the best
new habitats they are to the south and
the the west deliberately because they
are the parts of the site that are
closest to the countryside so there will
be a natural connectivity
the best part
in terms of
green corridors is actually along
footpath
13 and that's where on this site we're
enhancing the planting at the back of
this building
hopefully that's enough to satisfy you
that we haven't ignored our colleagues
at place services
because
i when i came before you before i
definitely
promoted the fact that we were going to
do some wonderful things on this site
not we but the applicants in terms of
creating habitats
that is our ambition and we will ensure
that that's what's delivered through
conditions where appropriate
thank you thanks
yep good answer
thank you for that any more questions
for the officer
um
we seem to ah hang on up who's that
has a hand gone up no it's gone down
right um we seem to have um the
applicant is that mr
said
we should have be uh sorry to interrupt
we should have the agent here today uh
nick davey and ben
oh is mr davey there then um if you'd
like to speak
um can you hear me
yes i thought
what is your name please both is nick
davey
all right hello it's just coming up as
mr job on me yeah i'm with mrs i'm using
his uh laptop
mr show and mr maxwell are here they're
they're both from the developer
uh they're here to answer any questions
that members may have
right if you'd like to give your
presentation then thank you very much
well thank you very much for your time
um i think this is about the sixth time
um
i've appeared before members uh
promoting the development of port one
and uh
as vincent said uh demand for the site
remains very very strong and buoyant
in fact um if we had more floor space we
could let two or three times the amount
of floor space we have
members have already granted detailed
approval for the first two units in
three and four
and um
you have a
reserve matters before you for another
three this application concerns uh
units one and two
and i can confirm the tenants are signed
up
the buildings have been designed to meet
their specific requirements
and work will start on site within weeks
of permissions being granted and the
other conditions presidents being
discharged
um
as uh
your plagues have said units one and two
they sit at the entrance to the site
opposite unit three
the design layout parking provision
landscaping and in particular the
banding of the materials and the
elevations that follows principles
established by previous consents
um
and that was important when we first
started out with this scheme
the site is open to short distance views
there are very few medium distance views
but there are some long views from the
other side of the valley
and that was felt was a critical view
that when you see the buildings against
the backdrop of the greaser trees along
the western boundary which are all
taller than anything we're going to put
on the site
that the dark top of the trees would be
the buildings will be seen and blend
into the dark tops of the trees so as
much as we can
it would disappear into the landscape
and have the minimum impact from those
views
and as uh your planets have said all the
buildings are of a common height
um just a couple of updates um
the new junction to brownford road
that will be open we hope uh within the
next couple of weeks
it should be has been open by now that
we came across a cave and gas pipe that
no one knew about which has put works
back a little bit
but it should be open within the next 10
days to a fortnight
work on the cycleway and footpath on the
west side of brantford road
that commences uh in february and should
be completed by easter
and that will also deliver the new
toucan crossing
um further up branford road near the
addison way so linking the site to the
new residential developments
um
in terms of the incinerator plant we are
now got full head to terms agreed
um the matters are in legals and
hopefully again the contracts will be
signed by easter
one contract will last for 23 years
and over the full term it could
result in 300 million pounds worth of
energy being purchased from that site
i can confirm that all the energy
is rock certified that's a renewable
obligation certificate and it is that
green 30 we will be taking it all
it's up to 10
megs
um and it will when the delivered into
the site we've got to put the
infrastructure in as well but it should
make
uh port 100 renewable energy driven
that's on top of all the photovoltaic
cells that we're delivering at the
moment
which i can confirm do uh
um
uh cater for the full 10 of the full
energy use of each building so that
would be the lighting the faultless
truck trucks the heating everything
um
a couple of questions were raised by
members i can confirm that the planting
strips at the front of that uh
image you have for one and two they're
five to seven meters
deep that's plenty of room to establish
a good planting strip
um i'm happy to answer any other
questions that members may have but i
hope that you can uh
grant with the master's approval and we
can do it with 150 plus jobs on units
one and two which the
tenants have said they will create
thank you very much
happy to
we are happy to
answer them as best we can that's very
helpful thank you very much indeed
members do you have any questions please
no i think everything has been bottomed
out very thoroughly and as you say it's
been several times um i can't is there a
question is somebody's hand up who's
that
ah councillor casten sorry i didn't see
you on the list though yeah
thank you very much
um
i just wondered if there's some
the the way these lorries um
um
unload here would there ever be a chance
that laurie might need to be unloaded
sideways by a
forklift no no no they have uh
uh the whole the buildings for all the
buildings on the site including units
one and two
are designed with those level duck
loaders so they come straight off
uh the docks the and the lorries the
better the lorries at the same level as
a dock
yeah okay no brilliant it did look like
that but i was just making sure and the
other thing is um the um
the actual
amount of lorry traffic coming in and
out of both these sites
um you can you can sort of see where
you could sort of stack up a couple of
lorries on both sides um while they wait
to be unloaded but um
how much
how much demand will there be for
lorries to be unloaded on the site per
day say or are we likely to see more
than
two lorries stacked there at any one
time waiting for other lorries to be
unloaded is basically what i'm saying um
we don't anticipate that'll be the case
one uh advantage of having all these
sites pre-elected that we have designed
the buildings to meet the tenants
requirements
so they are designed to cater for the
amount of lorries and the frequency of
lorry visits that the tenants tell us
are coming in so it's not a bespoke so
it's not a speculative scheme where
we're dealing with industry averages we
are dealing with the specific
requirements of each tenant
[Music]
and that would um
and that wouldn't be so much that you
would see
uh laurie coming in that didn't have a
space to park or had nowhere to um to
stack
for this development right okay thank
you
thank you very much any further
questions
no right oh yeah who's that
who else has put their hand up for a
question i can't see no gone down
i think we're all there um i know
alyssia has got a statement from the
ward member thank you very much indeed
um for um the applicants thank you thank
you um alicia would you like to read the
statement from the ward council please
thank you
of course chair thank you so this is a
note from john field who is the district
councillor for blakenham he says the
reserved matters proposal just hold on a
minute alicia was it for this one or for
the second one
um in his email he has listed it for 6d
but i believe the um
the contents of the email uh relate to
this application as well so it might be
appropriate
you might have
held off sorry i was jumping the gun
right far away thank you no worries
the reserve matters proposals refined
the outline application that has been
previously approved
i'm generally in favor of commercial
development
as it is close to the clayton access to
the a14 within i believe 600 meters
there have been fears that the
additional traffic generated will cause
congestion at peak times but i feel that
when the access currently being
constructed is complete the issue will
not be significant on brantford road
despite the proximity to other
commercial development including clayton
business park the incinerator and
landfill sites
the issue at the claydon a14 junction is
of concern is substantial tailbacks
occur at the moment at least to the
river crossing but it is impossible to
get action from county highways a 20-car
tailback is clearly not severe
i would wish to see the approach
proposed to outline with substantial
weight given to environmental concerns
and biodiversity improvements continued
the impact on our climate should be
minimized wherever practical
with building insulation improved to
high standards compared to other
developments for the intended building
use
the installation of low carbon heat
sources and solar panels to the greatest
extent reasonable would also demonstrate
an understanding of the issues that
challenge us now and a willingness to
build for the future without the need
for extensive refurbishment at a later
date
improves in these areas are improvements
sorry in these areas would move the
residents and me from generally in favor
to full support for a development that
should bring a substantial number of
jobs hopefully skilled and increase
prosperity to blakkenham regards council
john field
thank you very much indeed now um if uh
anyone who hasn't spoken would like to
speak on the application um
councillor muller thank you
yes um thank you very much chair um i
must admit from having listened to uh
vincent's presentation which was
excellent and and the comments from from
the applicant etc um this this this i do
like this application uh sustainable
source of energy electric power shuttle
bus new jobs ev charging good access i
like the new woodland and the
landscaping and obviously the parish
county and the member are happy with it
so if we're in a situation normal
committee i'll be happy um to support
this application chair thank you thank
you very much indeed councillor um any
other councillors who haven't spoken can
i have a few comments from you
councillor norris please thank you
uh thank you chair
um i just have one question actually
which has just occurred to me there was
mention regarding the access of the
lorries exiting onto bradford road not
being possible to turn
left and they have to turn right
to join the link through the a14 so how
is that actually implemented in practice
vince can you just give us a yes
there will be um the geometry
sorry on your screen because i'm not on
youtube on your screen have you got the
layout that shows units one and two
yeah yeah so at this point the geometry
will be such
that you won't be able to swing your
vehicle
your hgv left
because they'll be
extended
kerbs they're not the normal height
curbs they're
they're extended height curbs and
there'll be a nib
so you're physically
only able to turn right there will be a
no left turn sign
um but also included in the improvements
in the later phase of development
is signalization
as well
so the immediate answer to your question
council anarchy is it will be physically
impossible to turn an hgv left because
of the
the geometry that's being created in
here
but there'll also be no left turn for
htv
so at this point
it is down to the road engineering at
that point yes
we supplemented with signage and
signaling
correct
thank you very much
in due course
right yes thank you
and so councillor norris what sort of
steer would you be giving on this one
then
um well if these measures are already
proposed and i'm satisfied that
the question has been resolved actually
thank you
thank you
councillor mellon
uh yeah thank you chair um
yeah i think it's a
very comprehensive
uh
presentation as we as we've got used to
with them mr pissed um and um i think
generally i don't have any particular
problems with this and
would be happy to um if it were if we
were a normal committee to to vote in
favor of this i will just make a couple
of comments if that's okay
just a couple of things from the
presentation um i don't think it's
universally accepted that free ports are
a good thing
um just put that out there
um a very interesting article in the
guardian yesterday on export processing
zones and
certainly question marks over some of
the the tax treatment
and then also the comment about um this
development causing a net reduction
in hgv traffic i i have to sort of take
issue with that a little bit because i
feel that is really speculation rather
than anything we can base this on but
otherwise i'm happy with this happy to
um
be in favor of it thank you
thank you very much indeed anyone else
who would like to speak
no
um well i think you've all oh councillor
stringer
thank you chair yeah i i think this
application where it's got to now and
the good works of the officers with the
applicant have got it to a place where
it actually addresses virtually all of
what the ward member was actually
concerned with
it it does appear we've ended up with a
design that is actually 21st century
compliant
what we need to get is a a lorry fleet
that's also 21st century compliant to go
with the with the ultra modern building
so if i were on a committee would they
vote i would probably be voting in favor
thank you chair
thank you very much councillor uh
councillor casten's put his hand up
again yes please do
yeah thank you um
looking at this before the only issue
that i had with it and um i'm a big fan
of these developments i think this is
this is a really important development
optimizing like land that we you know
there's a big demand for the what was
worrying me is those lorries the um
in the top right is the cycle
um
park
and um the cars all being in that same
area using that same entrance um
i think um
i think the way that this has been
described and set out it doesn't seem
like that um loading area is
particularly um
lively
because the the way the um lorries back
up onto the um onto the ramps onto the
um
into the loading bays
but um the only thing that i can see
that does worry me a little bit is the
fact that cycles
will be going in through those entrances
where the lorries could be moving around
and also cars coming in um i did wonder
whether there was this
there is a bit of space there to have an
area that's
just for um cycles to go down um
to get to that cycle park at the back um
that lorries that keeps them separated i
don't know if that's an issue or not to
the other counselors but um it was just
something that came into my head when i
was looking at how that
works so that you know all those
different vehicles working together in
that entrance can i make a response
through you chair to councillor casten's
point
absolutely yes please because as i
showed
this will be
an improved pedestrian and cycle
connection through here
and i would suggest
to the chief planning officer that i
could discuss with the applicants
whether or not it's possible to get a
a cycle connection from a point
this side of the junction through the
site that would actually mean
we have segregated cycle movements from
the
hgv movements to me that seems
an eminently sensible suggestion
it's probably one i should have thought
of myself so i'm grateful councillor
cast and you probably have helped us
find a much neater solution
and a safer solution
in terms of this so depending on how our
discussions went but that is something
i'd be happy to discuss with the
applicants through the
chief planning officer
just noting what you're saying that
would be for um the unit one how would
they yes well they're in terms of units
two because this is a deck and the
pedestrians access is up here and cycle
access i think it's less of an issue for
unit two but i can actually
i do get councillor castings point yeah
i think it's a good point while made and
i'd like to think the applicants could
accommodate that quite easily
we'll we'll put that as a point for
mr isabel to put on his to-do list
anyone else wishing to speak
no there's only myself um yes i think
everybody's said everything about it
it's come back several times the ward
members happy with it huge amount of
work gone into it
very pleasing
and the the latest uh comment regarding
that uh improvement if it's possible i
think would be very helpful so i would
um
be approving this should this be a
normal
uh planning
meeting or
offering my approval anyway so there we
are so mr isbelt you just want to sum up
with what we might have before us um
to sort of agree taking forwards and
what you've heard what your steer might
be uh well thank you chairman yes i've
heard um fairly positive words i do need
to pick up on the point that vincent was
describing and what uh he was suggesting
there but before we do that um
i would just ask one question to my own
bat which is that the report
does talk about recommending the grant
of planning permission and i think this
is a reserve matters application so i
think that's one of those deliberate
errors that officers put in their
reports from time to time
both to cheek the chief planning officer
and to
make sure members stay on their their
their um
but it also ensures that the case
officers keep on their metal too it's a
point well made
assuming
you are right then the question that
council casted raised
perhaps we can just rehearse what your
thinking is there i i think as part of
the detailed landscaping proposals
we can accommodate
some hard surface hard landscaping that
would allow cyclists to connect to the
new
crossing point
uh yeah that seems to be a condition we
can adequately add to uh to this uh so i
think that's um
and effectively an additional condition
to enable the landscape and hard
landscaping detail to facilitate um
cycle access to the uh the new crossing
point um and i think that's an enemy
sensible thing to do apart from that
chairman i don't believe i've
picked up on anything that needs to be
added as a condition and i'm that's not
to be corrected
i've written nothing on my piece of
paper this time
okay
uh so with that single edition chairman
uh i think
my sense here is that uh i mean i'm
minded to accept the recommendation uh
put for a grant of reserve matters
consent with that additional condition
to ensure that the hard landscaping does
enable cycle access in the way that's
been described
thank you very much indeed excellent
thank you everybody
and we now move on to the final agenda
item
dc 2105 820 in a similar area um but we
have alicia who
but now wait a minute is it averill it's
going to thank you pardon i've got all
my a's muddled up here so overall
yes
avril if you would like to present the
case for us
thank you very much
thank you chair let me just um
oh that's
okay hopefully you can you can see that
and hear me okay
indeed yep
brilliant so
this application is um
on the same outline application that
vince has just presented for units one
and two it is also reserved matters for
appearance layout scale and landscaping
so also just a reminder that it is in
great blakendam which is a key service
center
so the hatched area is the location of
unit six
and in terms of constraints you've got
the public right-of-way
going around the site to the north and
the west and another public right-of-way
to the south
you've also got a cluster of grade two
listed buildings to the southeast of the
site
so yeah in terms of the location it's
located to the west of unit four which
as vince said that's already constructed
and is
occupied with unit 3 to the east under
construction
in terms of access so
this red dot shows um hg v m hgv
movements from branford road
into the site as you can see they pass
along black acre road
and into the northern access point
and the same route would be taken for
cars
into the southern access point um
where the parking area is
and the same applies with the exit from
the site goes back along black acre road
with the same
right turn only for hgvs
in terms of layout you have the delivery
docks to the north with the car park to
the south
we've also secured through discussions a
um
pedestrian crossing which is proposed in
the location flashing blue
that we're proposing to secure our
condition
and just a zoomed in version of the
layout you can see it's comprised of
warehouse
there's two mezzanines
and an office space
and again just
to highlight the delivery through the
north night sorry northern access
and the light blue
the car park to the south
and again um the same as units one and
two we have the same um
sort of delivery of electric vehicle
charging the green showing um
full apparatus so
with the infrastructure installed in
entirety and for use
with the blue
squares showing those with the apparatus
that
can be connect at future date
in terms of elevations again they're
following the same design principles
previously agreed
with the banded cladding
this is the elevation that you'll see
when you approach the site
as the frontage you have the glazing for
the office at the front
with the delivery docks
and this is the western elevation so the
rear that faces the mature
tree belt
so won't be seen from
any wider views from the west
and the southern elevation here you can
see the shallow pitched roof
following again the same design
principles agreed
with the office on the far right with
the flat roof
and again the same with the northern
elevation
just as a cross section through just
unit six in this case you
the tree belt to the west is existing
and recent measurements of the tree top
show it to be
53
aod so above ordinance datum
and the ridge will be set at 50.5
so you'll see that from the west
it is about two and a half meters
lower than the tree top
and just a reminder again of the
building heights um this is the same as
vince has shown so again following the
same kind of principles um and heights
across the site
obviously appreciating the leveling and
the finished floor levels
and then a wider site section you've got
unit six which is obviously this
application on the left
with kind of the red
lines into the ground just showing the
application site area
and then you can also see
the magnus building kind of central
which is not part of this site but then
you've got
unit 4 which is the one that's
built and occupied and then you can just
see a snippet of
unit 3 to the to the far right
and again
as
i mentioned obviously the site levels
there is
to get the floor level and the ridge
to an acceptable kind of level below the
treetops they are doing some
um leveling and removing some soil there
and in terms of the floor plans again
they follow the same similar um
premise with the
racking
on the ground floor
um and this is just a closer section of
the
offices uh ground floor on the left and
first floor on the right
and this is the first floor of the
warehouse
in the bottom right hand corner it's
just a snippet of the kind of third bay
of
the building just to show the kind of
relationship between the mezzanine
floors and the office
so this blue just highlights the
mezzanine on the first floor
and the same with the second floor
uh the mezzanine here
and in terms of the roof
the same shallow pitch
roof here
and you can see just an indicative
solar array pv around the roof
and just some context and some recent
site photos
this is
taken just from kind of the edge of the
plot for unit six and you can see the
mature tree belt um kind of
running across
the length of that image
there and this is kind of
north of the site looking across
you can just see the magnus building
kind of in the corner of the left
of that and then unit three no unit four
sorry central um there
and then
um looking down across kind of um
out of the site with the tree belt on
the right hand side
and another one of the magnus building
and you can see the
waste
plant with the big chimney
central there
and just in terms of jobs and i vince
mentioned
the number four units one and two the
approximate number for
unit six is about 70 full-time jobs
and again
obviously this this is pre-let so
it has been designed in accordance with
the requirements of the tenant
and landscaping obviously this site
doesn't have any kind of public road
frontages
um and you benefit from the western tree
belt so
the proposal was for some interspersed
trees around the car parking area and to
the frontage
but as it mentions in the report there
is hard and soft landscaping conditions
on the outline which require details to
be submitted i believe prior to slab
level
of this phase
and again just similar to vince has
mentioned um
the blakeland estate um
screening obviously you have the western
tree belt and this site does fall
outside of it
and again our recommendation is
as out in the report
um with an additional condition which
was submitted by table papers for
the delivery and details of the
pedestrian crossing
um
yeah thank you
thank you very much indeed do members
have any questions
no i think you've stunned us into
silence on this
it's not like us at all
that was very very helpful and very
clear and i thought the photographs and
the cross sections and everything were
putting the whole thing in perspective
thank you very much overall
right um
so
if there are no questions moving on um
if the applicant would like to say a few
words
um please do
uh
thank you chair uh can you hear me again
yes yes you're fine loud and clear i'll
try and keep this as short as i can not
not
we're told by the tenant we'll deliver
75 jobs
it is pre-led as every other term on the
site
um
and has been designed again for the
specific requirements of the tenant
um nothing on port one is speculative
um
again it follows the principles
established at the outline stage and
with all the other reverb matters
particularly in terms of height and
cladding materials and
this is where the um
the use of the cladding materials and
the way we're banding them will
hopefully really show its benefits
because this is the the units which are
hardest up against the
the tree belt on the western boundary
and we've worked very hard to ensure
that the ridge of the the um
the height of the roof is below the the
tree belt it's at least three meters
below the average height of those trees
some of the trees are are taller than
that but it's at least two and a half
three meters
uh below the height of the average so
that when you see it from the
uh any long distance views from the east
it will blend as much as we can into the
background
um
just sort of carrying on from a couple
of things that were mentioned earlier
um when we get the um
the power comes across from the suez
plant
um the current requirement is that we
provide 20
pv spaces now
uh with the infrastructure for the next
20 percent
um i've just spoken to the client and we
can now commit to doing 40 from day one
on units one two and six and any other
units have come forward
um
also just an update on the uh
uh again we're
listening to the
contracts for every tenant is that uh
they can only use uh forklift trucks on
the site which are not powered by diesel
or petrol that's not going to be
electric and that's written into all the
contracts including for unit 4
which is already up and running and the
shuttle bus itself that is on order that
is fully electric
that will be in place before unit 3
opens which is the planning requirement
and that should be running
april may this year
um
as i can help members of anything else
um i just want to say that such as the
demand for the site that hopefully
within the next uh four weeks or
fortnight
will be coming with reserve matters for
the units to the north of uh plot six
units seven eight nine and ten we
already have uh tenants lined up after
three of those four units was it all
four
all four units so they're also pre-let's
they'll be coming in with the next two
weeks such as the demand for the site
so um again unless uh you have any
questions
members are there's a handgun up there
councillor custom first please thank you
hi yeah just to pick up on that um no
diesel or petrol powered forklifts um
do you consider a gas
um powered forklift is that and it does
that come under petrol it's a form of
petrol but um
because most forklifts i know are
gas-powered
yes i mean we don't know where the
technology is going to go in the future
you could get hydrogen powered but um
yeah
at the moment everyone's using an
electric fullness
there'll be a yeah they'll be electric
or something better yeah yeah no problem
at all thank you
that's very useful anyone else who'd
like to speak
no i think we're all there and
so
again we've had the report from
uh councillor field
that covered both of these so i think
really we just either by a tacit
agreement of non-discussion um or
whether we uh sort of give
give here we are dave muller councillor
molly to give philip his steer
yeah
thank you very much chair and and thank
you for all again for your presentation
yeah i totally support this application
so um although we can't vote on it if we
were able to vote i will be voting in
favor of this application thank you
chair
thank you for that anyone else like to
pass comments
well i'll just agree with that as well
and i think if you take the silence is
golden
we usually find people commenting things
if they aren't happy with things
generally i saw a comment the other day
which said silence is golden unless you
have a border terrier in which case be
very worried
and i have and i am
so um
it's been a wonderful uh line up on this
uh application so
are you happy with what you've heard
phillip uh chairman i'll i'll take i'll
take the absence of silence as uh as
sufficient comfort that members don't
feel troubled by the recommendation as
it presently stands
uh and
with that in mind
i am just checking to make sure that
this is the reserve matters application
in the recommendation oh no it's another
planning permission i think if you could
just confirm that
yes sorry that's a typo excellent
keeping me on my toes thank you for that
so uh yes so
the subject to that i think
i i take it chairman that uh that i'd be
minded to
grant reserve matters consent according
to the recommendation
thank you very much can i just thank
everyone
for their input today
and i hope that we've come up with
something to give
philip good steer over but thank you for
everybody's participation
and the the way in which it was all
taken so with that um the meeting is now
closed
2
you